Schon 17 Leute da, Massive Viewer Anzahl, Hallo Max wie gehts, ich war heute wieder
unglaublich viel für meine Verhältnisse, für meine Verhältnisse unglaublich viel
im freien, man glaubt das kaum, ich mach ja sogar manchmal Fotos, guckt
euch das mal an, so viel, so viel Sonne, das war nicht normal, ja ich hab also ich
ich hab wahrscheinlich echt bald auf dem Kopf in Sonnenbrand, wobei ich hab hier
immer meine Kappe auf, ich hab meine Asus, meine Asus Mütze auf, ne die hab ich
eigentlich nicht oft auf, ich bin gerade aufgefallen, die müsste ich immer aufziehen, ich hab
eine Asus Mütze hab ich, alternativ, ich hab mal ne Weile Kappen gesammelt, ich hab
alle möglichen Kappen, ich hab ne Halo Kappe, ich hab ne Black Ops Kappe, ich hab
ne Asus Kappe, ich hab ne Destiny Kappe, hab ich noch, relativ viele, ach keine Ahnung,
auch die Jahre wo ich auf die Gamescom gegangen bin, hab ich immer Kappen gesammelt wenn
das möglich war, eine Killer Fisch Kappe stimmt null, das gibt es gar nicht mal, ich
hab ne Nip Kappe, ganz vergessen, ohne Fanatic Kappe, haha, stimmt, stimmt ich erinnere mich
noch an CS sein, ich hab ne Ria Cloud Kappe, falls das jemand kennt, ja keine Ahnung, ist
auch egal, ich muss noch kurz Bombe umglutschen, aber sonst ich muss sagen, mein Hals ist schon
wieder viel viel besser als noch vor ein paar Wochen, aber immer noch nicht weg, Leute ich
nehme jetzt abend vorm schlafen gehen so ne komische Paste gegen Sodbrennen, ja ja ich
weiß Boomer Talk ne, aber vielleicht hilft das tatsächlich was ja, es ist so komisch
schleimig, so ne komische schleimige Paste, die muss man langsam, steht zumindest aber
langsam runter schlucken, naja, ärztetechnisch kann man es auch vergessen, ich war jetzt schon
bei ein paar, wirklich gute Beratung gibt es da auch nicht, ach egal, so Leute ich zeige
euch mal, oder ich sag euch mal was wir heute machen, wir machen heute Massive PogChamp
Zeug, das reicht als Erklärung oder, ich glaub das reicht, ne aber, ich hab mir doch
so ein Dymo Labelwriter gekauft, das haben wir doch zusammen im letzten Stream gebastelt
hier guck mal, so ein Teil, Titan Toast, Dankeschön, Huge Massive 20 Millionen, das ist der Drucker
mit DRM, bzw. der hat noch kein DRM, die anderen haben DRM, ich habe so ein Ding gekauft und
mein Ziel ist ja, dass ich ein Raspberry Pi dran hänge per USB und ein Webinterface habe,
was ein bisschen aussieht wie Paint oder so, und da schreibe ich dann was rein und drück
auf drucken und kann vielleicht noch ein paar Bilder drumherum machen, drück auf drucken
und dann kommen die Label raus, der Labelwriter hat hier glaube ich noch gar kein DRM, die
neueren haben DRM, du hast deinen YouTube Account wieder, nice, ja, die sind da tatsächlich
auf Zack, auf Twitter, ursprünglich wollte ich ja Draw IO embedden, aber das ist Mist,
das hat nicht wirklich gut funktioniert, bisschen lauter, Leute, ich muss mal kurz was testen,
Lautstärke, Achtung, Lautstärke, Test von den Emoils, naja, wie sie zu laut sind sie
ja schon, das ist nicht von mir, leicht zu verwechseln, aber das was du geguckt hast
ist der Serious Max, das bin ich ich, das ist ein Mod, das ist aber ziemlich agibat vom
Name her, da gebe ich dir schon recht, also das kann man schon, das kann man ziemlich
schnell verwechseln, ja und was ich mir überlegt habe ist, der Label Champ, das wird ein JavaScript
Image, ganz ganz simpler JavaScript, Bildereditor, oder nicht Bildereditor, so Canvas Editor,
das machen wir da mit, guck hier gibt es ja zischtutorials zu und sowas, das machen wir
mit dieser Library, ConvaJS, jetzt habe ich jetzt, ich habe nur zwei Stück gefunden auf
den ersten Blick, ich habe Fabric und Conva oder so gefunden und das eine sieht besser
maintained aus, die richtig coolen Leute würden das wahrscheinlich mit WebGL machen, aber
da habe ich keinen Plan von, der Preis Champ, der ist abgeschaltet, den habe ich ausgemacht,
der ist aus, es war zu Paynes Champ den Crawler zu aktualisieren, da habe ich nicht weiter
gemacht, hast du dir schon mal Kotlin angeguckt, angeguckt, ja, gemacht, nie und ich habe es
auch nicht vor, ich habe es auch nicht vor, weil es ist Java-Stells und ich will weder
Android-Native entwickeln noch mich irgendwie sonst weiter mit Java beschäftigen und nachdem
ich absolut gar keinen Bock auf Java habe, wird es mit Kotlin auch nichts, machst du
mal ein Video von deinem Router-Setup, was willst du denn wissen, ich habe mal ein Bild
gemalt, Netzwerk, das da, hey guck mal, ich habe sogar noch in meiner History das Bild,
das Bild was wir mal zusammen gemalt haben von meinem Netzwerk, was willst du denn wissen,
da gibt es nicht viel, da gibt es nicht viel zu machen eigentlich, ich habe einen Mikrotik-Router,
so als einziges Gerät, was man Router nennen kann, was war es, aber noch mal kurz, noch
mal kurz, auf die schnelle, also, Netzwerk-technisch ist das bei mir daheim so, Recycled Story
Leute, Netzwerk-technisch ist das bei mir daheim, intern habe ich einen 10 Gigabit-Switch
von UniFi, einen Edge-Switch, äh, nicht UniFi, Ubiquiti, UniFi Crap, Alter, ich habe einen
Edge-Switch, 10 Gigabit Edge-Switch, kein UniFi-Switch, da hängen meine ganzen internen
Kisten dran, vom NAS bis zum Desktop-Rechner, gut, in Wirklichkeit geht hier noch ein Switch
an Schreibtisch, Desktop, Null, und hier hängen dann noch ein paar Sachen dran, aber das ist
ja wurscht, übrigens auch ein 10 Gigabit-Switch, so, und, ähm, also hier hängen die ganzen
internen Clients dran, sonst eigentlich nichts, dann kommt direkt da dran ein Mikrotik-Router,
der Mikrotik-Router macht eigentlich so ziemlich alles, was man machen muss, ähm, im Netzwerk,
von DHCP bis ein bisschen Firewall, bis Routen zwischen den Netzen, äh, bis PoE für die
Access Points, äh, unterschiedliche WLAN-Config, im Prinzip macht der mehr oder weniger alles,
was man hier machen muss, an dem einen Port hängt die Unity Media Connect Box dran, ist
da oben eigentlich so ein Strich, achso, das ist Internet hier, das ist, das ist Internet,
Internet schreiben wir mal dabei, so, äh, an einem hängt die Unity Media Connect Box
dran, warum, ähm, naja, irgendwas mit Kabelmodem muss halt Einwahl, oder wie auch immer man
das bei Kabel-Internet-Krams nennt, Einwahl, ich nenn's mal Einwahl, so ADSL-Moder machen,
das ist halt die Unity Media Connect Box in dem Fall, so, die hängt da dran, am gleichen
Port, äh, nicht am gleichen Port, an einem Port von der Connect Box hängt noch eine Fritz
Box dran, die Fritz Box macht aktuell aber nur Decktelefonie, ne, es ist nicht PoE,
es ist, frag mich nicht, wie das bei Kabel heißt, keine Ahnung, so, das ist die Internetseite,
und hier auf der Seite hab ich noch drei Access Points per Power Over Ethernet dran, einem
Keller, einem Erdgeschoss, einem ersten Stock, und es gibt zwei WLAN Netze, einmal eins für
normale Clients, vom Smartphone bis, äh, Tablet und, und alles mögliche, was es so
gibt, und eins für China-Chinesen-Krempel, ach, das kann man nicht mal editieren, MapaPaint,
boss ist schlecht, so, und ein WLAN für China-Chinesen-Kram, so, fertig, ja, ohne als Raspberry Pi hier
dran, als UniFi-Controller, aber das ist ja egal, so, so sieht das aus, äh, ich hatte
früher einen PF-Sense, äh, wobei kein PF-Sense, ich hatte früher einen Open-Sense, ich hatte,
ich hatte früher eine Open-Sense-Kiste, aber, das war zu Zeiten, wo ich diese fette, Moment,
ähm, ja, das war zu Zeiten, wo ich diese fette Server-Kiste hatte noch im Rack, diese
4HE, diese 4HE-Kiste, und da hatte ich so ziemlich alles drauf, da hatte ich eine VM mit Open-Sense
drauf, da hatte ich VM mit, mit, äh, Heim-Automatisierung drauf, da habe ich eine VM drauf gehabt, mit,
äh, TV-Hatend für Fernsehrecording, das war an sich wirklich technisch coole Sache, aber,
das Problem war halt, du konntest diese Kiste nie anfassen, wenn ich diese Kiste angefassen
habe und rebooted habe, ging nur nicht mal mit die Rollos richtig auf und zu, also das
war für'n Arsch, deswegen habe ich das alles etwas entzerrt, also sprich, ich habe jetzt
eine Kiste, die macht Router, ich habe eine Kiste, die macht Nass, ich habe eine Kiste
drüben im Wohnzimmer, die macht Aufnahme, das heißt, ich kann jetzt die Sachen unabhängig
voneinander auch mal rebooten oder Updates machen oder sonst was, ohne dass irgendwo
was schreit im Haus oder dass irgendwo, irgendwo was nicht funktioniert, so, natürlich, natürlich
hätte ich mir irgendwo anders eine Low-Power-Kiste hinstellen können, ich habe übrigens letztens
ein cooles Video gesehen, für so eine Kiste auf YouTube, das da, der Kerl hat letztens
eine coole Box dafür vorgestellt, das ist irgendein China-Chinesen-Ding, 4-Port, 2,5
Gigabit, das ist eine richtig coole, vor der Idee eine richtig coole PFSense-Box, sowas
hätte ich mir auch holen können, ja, aber mit PFSense machst du auch kein PoE, das
muss halt natürlich auch klar sein, also mir, ich kenne keine x86-Hardware, die PoE macht,
generell kenne ich keine normale Hardware, die PoE macht, so, und nachdem ich eigentlich
recht zufrieden bin mit den Router-OS-Settings von Mikrotik, gibt es kein PFSense-Open-Sense,
Open-Sense und PFSense machen aber tatsächlich in manchen Kombinationen Sinn, wenn man zum
Beispiel Gästezugang hat, also WLAN, WLAN-Gästezugang hat und dort, also keine Ahnung, man ist zum
Beispiel in irgendeinem Wohnheim oder so, Patrick, das ist gut, man ist vielleicht in
irgendeinem Studentenwohnheim oder so und hat dann WLAN-Zugang, wo man so, wir nennen
es so Voucher, so wie heißt das auf Deutsch, so Zettel mit Zugangsdaten ausgibt, die man
eintippen muss, ja, sowas lässt sich mit PFSense schön konfigurieren, das ist mit Mikrotik
nicht so nice, aber ansonsten, wozu, die Mikrotik-Dinger sind billig, deutlich billiger als irgendwie
so eine eigene Kiste zu bauen, die ordentlich was taugt und Router-OS hat ein schönes Webinterface
zum konfigurieren, also, sprich, man kann beides machen, ja, die richtig Hardcore-Netzwerk-Leute,
die sagen, ohne Cisco-Kommandozeile geht nix, die anderen sagen, ja, Open-WRT, was auch
immer, letztendlich ist das eigentlich wurscht, das kann alles mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
So, hast du auch Dienste in der Cloud laufen, die per VPN eingebunden sind, nee, ich hab
auch selbst meine ganze Geschichte nicht von außen erreichbar, ich hatte lange Zeit Open-VPN
laufen, aber ich hab festgestellt, ich brauch das gar nicht, ich hatte auch, also ich hatte
Jahre lang hatte ich das sogar, hatte ich Open-VPN am Eingang noch laufen, also was
hinterm Eingang mit Open-VPN, wo du dich dann erstmal autonifizieren musst, dass du jetzt
irgendwie eigentlich ins Netz kommst und da konnte ich von außen auf meine Heimautomatisierung
zugreifen und solche Dinger, aber das brauch ich nicht, ich habe das bis auf ein paar Sachen
so nach dem Motto, ja cool, cool jetzt zu sehen, aber eigentlich brauch ich es nicht, nie für
was Sinnvolles genutzt, deswegen mach ich es jetzt anders, es gibt zum Beispiel meine Bewegungsdaten
und sowas, die schicke ich über den MQTT-Server, der steht im Internet, da ist meine Heimautomatisierung
dran subscribt, da brauch ich kein VPN für und ansonsten, sowas anderes interessiert
mich eigentlich von unterwegs nicht, ja da kann man übrigens relativ coole Sachen machen,
zum Beispiel hat Home Assistant eine Integration, da kannst du gucken, bewegst du dich von zuhause
weg, bewegst du dich auf zuhause zu und wenn ja, wie schnell und dann kann das ausrechnen,
wann bist du daheim und wenn du näher bist als XY dran, Minuten oder Kilometer, ich weiß
es gar nicht, nein Minuten, wenn du weniger als so viel Minuten weg bist von daheim, kannst
du darauf reagieren, zum Beispiel Klimaanlage im Sommer einschalten, 10 Minuten bevor du
heimkommst und sowas, ist eigentlich eine coole Sache, deswegen mache ich Bewegungsdaten
über den MQTT-Server im Internet und ansonsten, weder VPN, ich meine ich habe ein paar VMs
in der Cloud laufen, aber die machen, achja doch tatsächlich, ich habe noch eine für
Backup, aber das benutze ich nicht, da habe ich vor ein paar Wochen mal wieder angefangen,
ich habe gesagt Leute, endlich, ich muss mal endlich mich um Offside Backup kümmern, aber
ich habe mir gedacht, ich mache Hetzner Style, wer braucht Backup, hoffentlich hat es jetzt
keiner gehört, sonst wäre ich nicht mal gesponsert, ne habe ich nicht, wir machen übrigens demnächst
wieder was mit Hetzner, aber nicht Sponsort, ich habe mir schon was überlegt oder vielleicht
bis dahin Sponsort, mal gucken, ja, aber das war es, ja genau, nutzt du für Ladenwaren,
weder noch, ich habe weder intern im Netzwerk IPv6 noch ins Internet IPv6, ich habe Glück,
Unity Media, also Vodafone ist es jetzt, ja, ich habe einen vollwertigen IPv4 und IPv6
Anschluss und ich werde meinen Tarif auch nie umstellen, wenn du mir nicht garantieren
können, dass das so bleibt, ansonsten habe ich da auch keinen Ansatzzweck, warum kein
IPv6, weil du dich dann um viel mehr Sachen kümmern musst, du musst dich um alles doppelt
kümmern, zum Beispiel bei IPv4 geht das alles über Nut raus, bei IPv6 brauchst du extra
Firewall regeln, das geht alles, aber du musst dich um zwei verschiedene Sachen kümmern,
was doof ist, und intern habe ich keinerlei Vorteile durch IPv6, viele wichtigen Seiten
im Internet sind immer noch nicht über IPv6 erreichbar, für manche Sachen mag es ganz
praktisch sein, aber ansonsten, Vodafone Business, guck mal doch mal, guck mal doch mal was der
Campbell kostet, schau mal, das, das können wir uns gleich machen, bevor wir Progress
Stells machen, ich habe übrigens meine persönliche Theorie zu, ob sich IPv6 jemals durchsetzen
wird, soll ich euch die mal erzählen, und zwar, wenn man sich mal überlegt, IPv6 ist
wann standardisiert worden, weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, 1995 oder so, hier, 1998, da war
IPv4 noch nicht knapp, hat sich keine Sau für interessiert, so, ähm, Zugriff, Google
Vernutzer, ja wahrscheinlich, ja ok, ähm, ja die verwenden auch IPv6, auch, auch, weil
Google hat das ja auch, so, ähm, so, das hat jetzt quasi, sind wir mal nett, das hat
jetzt 22 Jahre gebraucht, bis sich das nennenswert verbreitet hat, es hat sich ja noch nicht
durchgesetzt, das kann man so nicht sagen, ähm, sag mal so, IPv6 hat mittlerweile aber
wenigstens immerhin nennenswerte Verbreitung, es gibt viele Seiten, die immer noch nicht
richtig per IPv6, ich glaube Amazon, war nicht Amazon auch nicht gescheit erreichbar IPv6,
irgendwie, es waren zig große Seiten, die nicht richtig ordentlich erreichbar sind
bei IPv6, so, deswegen ist meine Vermutung, wenn es sich jetzt in 22 Jahren nicht richtig
durchgesetzt hat, um gerade mal 60% in Deutschland erreicht hat, in weiteren 22 Jahren sind wir
vielleicht bei 80%, vielleicht, vielleicht, wenn es überhaupt so lang geht, ähm, und
wir haben von diesen 22 Jahren, wo das jetzt gebraucht hat sich durchzusetzen, mindestens
die letzten 5, wenn nicht 10 Jahre, wo IPv4 schon ziemlich knapp ist, so, meine persönliche
Vermutung ist daher folgendes, bevor IPv6 wirklich 100%, ja 100%, na gut, ja doch,
sag mal so, wir müssten eigentlich anstreben, dass IPv6 100% Abdeckung hat, ja, aber bevor
IPv6 90 plus Abdeckung hat weltweit, wird was anderes passieren, das ist meine persönliche
Vermutung, ihr könnt mir in den Chat schreiben, was ihr denkt, ja Patrick hat auch gerade
schon was ähnliches geschrieben, meine persönliche Vermutung ist, dass wenn der ganze Kram zu
Paynes Champ wird, und wenn Amazon, Twitch, Google, wenn die ganzen großen auch so richtig
abgefuckt sind und mit IPv4 nicht mehr weiter kommen, und jetzt zwangsweise IPv6 machen
müssen, ich glaube an diesem Zeitpunkt wird eins passieren, nämlich, dass die zusammen
was rausbringen, was nicht IPv6 ist, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das dann aussehen wird,
so ein bisschen wie diese Google HTTP Alternative, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass du zur HTTP nicht
wirklich eine Alternative brauchst, wie heißt denn das nochmal, Quip oder so, Quick, Quick,
dieses HTTP von Google, was glaube ich mittlerweile in Chrome drin ist, Quick, ja genau, die werden
sich zusammenschließen, gehe ich mal von aus, weil die haben alle das gleiche Problem,
und die werden irgendwas rausbringen, als Alternative zu IPv6, das ist standardisiert,
ja das wird das neue dann auch sein, die machen dann was neues, und was meint ihr, wenn Microsoft,
Facebook, Amazon, Twitter, Twitch, Google, alle möglichen, wenn die sich halbwegs einig
sind, was meint ihr, wie schnell es was neues gibt, und wie schnell das überall implementiert
ist, dass es schneller implementiert, als das standardisiert ist, und das wird dann wahrscheinlich
auch nicht IPv8 oder so heißen, das wird dann wahrscheinlich irgendeinen coolen trendlichen
Namen haben, was weiß ich, Fast IP oder irgendein Blödsinn oder sowas, Cloud IP, was auch immer,
die werden sich da irgendwas ausdenken, das ist ja, IP ersetzt man nicht mal so eben,
ja das sieht man ja bei IPv6, dass es nicht mal so eben geht, und IPv4 wirst du auch nie
komplett ersetzen können, ich geh nicht davon aus, dass wenn du was anderes hast, das jemals
wirklich 100% Abdeckung hat, aber bevor IPv6 sich an die 100% durchsetzt, glaube ich eher,
es wird irgendwas anderes von den großen sich ausgedacht, und das wird ratzfatz Verbreitung
haben, Linux hat sowas immer schnell, Windows hat immer sowas schnell, Android, IOS haben
sowas dann immer schnell, wenn die sich alle einig sind, und dann geht das schon, das Problem
ist natürlich noch die Server Seite, das ist ja jetzt auch schon, aber bin ich mal gespannt,
wenn man nämlich eins gelernt hat die letzten Jahre über ist, dass die wahnsinnig trickreich
sind was irgendwelche Hacks angeht, mich würde nämlich auch nicht wundern, wenn sie irgendeinen
Extended Layer zu IPv4 bauen zum Beispiel, na IPv4 geht ja weiter, mich würde auch nicht
wundern wenn die IPv4 Extended oder irgendwie sowas machen, mit irgendwie, wenn an dem und
dem und dem und dem Byte das richtige Lower Bit gesetzt ist, dann bedeutet das in dem
Frame ab Stelle 58 Bytes stehen da noch zwei zusätzliche Adressen oder irgendwie so ein
Bullshit, keine Ahnung, irgendwie sowas, ja Patrick, so da gehe ich auch von aus, ich
gehe davon aus, dass das nächste, wenn die sich was ausdenken vollständig kompatibel
zu IPv4 sein wird, plus irgendwelche Extended Sachen möglich macht und die haben schlaue
Leute, ich bin gespannt was da kommt, aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir sehen, dass IPv6
in 20 Jahren 100% hat oder so, oder 90 plus, ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen,
ja wenn du was wissen willst, sag Bescheid, VHS und Chill, du bist wahrscheinlich deutlich
jünger als das du VHS überhaupt miterlebt hast, oder, Facebook ist, hat Facebook als
IPv6, ok, Blue Media, aber was ist, wenn das Apple, Microsoft, Facebook und sonst wie machen,
dann ist das egal ob die Community das auslacht, das ist dann einfach mein allen wichtigen
Betriebssystem instant implementiert und da bin ich mal gespannt, da können die Leute
so viel lachen wie sie wollen, letztendlich wenn die sich halbwegs einig sind, dann läuft
der Laden, ja genau, hast du deine Klimaanlage im Smart Home eingebunden, ja habe ich, haben
wir sogar hier im Stream gebaut, guck mal, Archiv, Klima, Klima, Klimaanlage feels gut
man, eigene Steuerung feels amazing man, da haben wir solche Dinge gemacht mit irgendwelchen
Infrarot LEDs, mit irgendwelchen Infrarot LEDs, ja, mit Bastelchamp gemacht, mit irgendwelchen
Infrarot LEDs haben wir die Klimaanlage angesteuert, da war was, ja, bei Hetzner ist irgendein
Raid 6 verreckt oder wie war das, Hetzner Raid 6, ja, bei Hetzner ist irgendein Raid
6 verreckt, kommt vor, es war ja auch nur bei den, das muss man an der Stelle vielleicht
auch mal sagen, das war ja auch nur bei den Budget angeboten, da muss man eigentlich selber
gucken, dass das ordentlich gesichert ist, ich meine Cloud Anbieter sollte es nicht absichtlich
kaputt machen, aber irgendwo müssen günstige Preise ja herkommen, machen wir vielleicht,
ja, aber vielleicht, wenn ich wirklich mal was eingerichtet habe, korrekt, das glaubt
nicht, dass Modern Warfare 2 in irgendeiner Art und Weise schon IPv6 macht, achja wir
wollten Business Verträge von Vodafone gucken, Handytarife, what the fuck, Internet und Festnetz,
zum Angebot, denn die Verfügbarkeit prüfen kann Hetzner schlecht, so, die ersten 6 Monate,
ok, das kostet ungefähr das gleiche, das kostet ungefähr das gleiche, wie das was
ich aktuell bezahle, nur mit dem Unterschied, da ist kein Fernsehanschluss dabei, das ist
nur Kabelanschluss ohne Fernsehcrempe, was blöd ist, weil, gucken Fernseh über Kabelanschluss,
was mobile flat, ich will keine mobile flat, nur Internet reicht mir, guck mal es war noch
ein bisschen billiger, beste IP, man kann die bestimmt ändern lassen, ja, vielleicht
mache ich das wirklich, wie nennt sich das denn jetzt, Red Business Internet, wie machen
man das denn wenn man darüber Fernseh gucken will, das ist ja da wahrscheinlich nicht dabei,
das braucht man wahrscheinlich zusätzlich noch, gehe ich mal von aus, kostet er nochmal
20 Euro oder sowas, nee, Weipus sagt, alle, alle Internet, alle, wie nennt sich das, IPTV
Anbieter, außer die, die über Torrent oder sonst was funktionieren, die die nicht offiziell
sind, zacken, ich guck kein Fernseh mehr, meine Mutter guckt Fernseh, guckt jeden Abend
so 3-4 Stunden Fernseh und die steht auf Oldschool Kram und die guckt sich dann auch so Sachen
an wie Rosamunde Pilcher oder sowas, und die ist das gewohnt, dass die ins Kodi gehen kann,
in den EPG und Sachen programmieren, ja die gucken tatsächlich auch Tatort unsere Dinger,
Mediathek checkt sie nicht, die gehen in den EPG, nimmt Sachen auf, guckt sich dann Sachen
an, das kannst du mit Weipu nicht gescheit machen, du hast online Storage dort, aber
irgendwie nur 100 oder 50 Stunden oder 100 Stunden oder sowas und dann musst du es auch
mit der offiziellen App gucken, weil du es nicht aus der App rausbekommst, das ist alles
Müll, Jarek ja das ist nur die Sache, wenn du einen Business Vertrag hast, hast du wahrscheinlich
kein Fernseh dabei, kannst überspringen, so ok,
ne Kodi ist nice dafür, Kodi ist finde ich das beste Frontend, was du haben kannst auf
dem Fernseh, gibt dir nichts anderes gescheit, wenn du die Sachen mit dem eigenen Tuner gucken
willst, ja siehste, das meine ich ja, man braucht ein extra Vertrag, der kostet dann
auch noch mal 20-23 Euro, das heißt ich bezahle 50 Euro Business Internet und noch mal 20
Euro, bei so viel teurer ist das gar nicht, als das was ich aktuell bezahle, vielleicht
mach ich das einfach, ja ich hab welche, aber benutze ich gerade, ja aber ich hab kein
Yubi Key, ich hab irgendein Alternativding, ich weiß gar nicht wo er liegt gerade, ist
kein Yubi Key, ich hab irgendeinen bei anderen, aber ich finde das vor allem Ansatz her eigentlich
eine echt coole Geschichte, ich mein, bessere zwei Faktor als das Handy oder so auf jeden
Fall, oder was heißt besser, andere, Plex ist gut wenn du Sachen wie Torrent runtergeladen
Videos gucken willst und sowas, aber Plex für live TV im Zusammenhang mit irgendeinem
Backend Server, wo dann der TV Stick dran ist und sowas, ist das auch ziemlich ein Müll,
Plex ist gut wenn du dir über Torrent 20 Filme gezogen hast oder über die letzten
Jahre 50 Filme und willst dadurch die Library Browsen und sowas, ja meinetwegen, das ist
auch der einzige Grund warum die Leute noch Plex am Start haben und warum ich noch nie
den, ich hab ja noch nie den Anwendungszweck für Plex erkannt, so wirklich bei mir, aber
gut für die Leute die sich permanent Sachen ziehen, dann verstehe ich das, wie soll denn
das funktionieren gescheit, für Plex brauchst du, du brauchst in irgendeiner Art und Weise
was wo du dann DVB-C Signal rein kriegst, so, ich guck über den Shield TV am Fernseh,
den Tuner kann ich definitiv nicht an Shield TV dran machen, da gibt es keine Treiber für
Plex, und das heißt ich müsste irgendwie einen Plex Server Backend haben, wo es dann drüber
aufnehmen kann und der TV Stick, und das ist mir nicht bekannt, dass es überhaupt geht,
worauf du es laufen lässt hat doch gar nichts mit der Funktionalität von Plex zu tun, der
Chat wieder, guckt sie euch an hier, so Battlesheep sagt, habe meine Projekte bisher immer mit
ASP.NET Core Inclusive Server-Side Rendering, siehste, das mach ich kaum, ich mach kaum Server-Side
Rendering. Ja, XTV M3U Proxy für Plex, ja geil, das ist für IPTV über irgendwelche
russischen IPTV Server, ich rede davon, ein DVB-C Tuner zu haben, über den ich gucke.
Ja, Svelte heute wieder, ja. Ja, muss man sich mal angucken. Exzellent.
Peace, Batman. Achso, ja, zeig mal her, habe meine Projekte bisher immer mit ASP.NET Core
Inclusive Server-Side Rendering gemacht, wie gesagt Server-Side Rendering mach ich kaum,
ich bin die letzten Jahre schon auf dem Single-Page, auf dem Spar-Trend-Trip, ja. Momentan teste
ich verschiedene Frontend-Frameworks, da braucht es dann aber immer eine separate API, die
man entwickeln muss. Ja, ist das nicht deutlich mehr Aufwand im Gegensatz zu reiner, ja, ja,
naja, es kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, was man machen muss, also ja, im Prinzip schon,
wobei man halt auch oftmals die Server-Seite dann deutlich weniger ausbauen muss, weil
du viele Sachen halt kleinzeitig in JavaScript machst, also ja, prinzipiell schon, kommt
aber ein bisschen drauf an, auf der anderen Seite ist halt Server-Side Rendering für interaktive
Sachen kacke, es sei denn du schickst den initialen State quasi mit rüber und machst
dann obendrauf JavaScript kleinzeitig, was ja aktuell übrigens jeder Trend ist, wenn
man sich mal Next, Nuxt und uns Weltkit und Gedöns anguckt, ich copypaste mir das mal
alles chat, ich gucke mir das nachher an. Ja, also wie gesagt, das ist ja auch der aktuelle
Trend, wenn man sich anguckt hier Next, Nuxt, Weltkit, sonst was in der Richtung, das ist
ja quasi der neueste Trend, was Web-Anwendungen angeht, weil das nämlich Server-Seite Rendering
und Single-Page-Application verbindet, also da wird dann ein initialer Stand der Applikation
auf dem Server gerendert, wird quasi in, der JavaScript-State wird quasi zusammengepackt,
wird rübergeschickt an den Client, der Client bekommt die Seite, dehydrated sich, nennt
sich so, den State wieder und läuft dann an der Stelle weiter. Das hat den Vorteil, du
kannst bessere Suchmaschinenoptimierung machen und der Client hat die Sache schneller geladen
und offen. Static ist ja quasi, wenn du so willst Server-Seite Rendering, nur dass nichts
gerendert werden muss, also nichts dynamisch gerendert werden muss. So, ach so, das ist
gestern rausgekommen. Es hat nicht so ganz funktioniert. Ja musst du, musst du. Da musst
du allein schon aus dem Grund, weil du ja neben dem initialen Stand Nick Server-Seite
renderst und der Client weiter abfragen muss. Was ich persönlich eine wirklich nice Kombination
finde, ist GraphQL mit Subscriptions. Dann brauchst du meistens für kleine Sachen, wohlgemerkt
ja, für kleine Sachen brauchst du meistens so sagen wir mal ein Endpunkt, worüber permanent
die Updates geschickt werden. Du brauchst nicht 50 Rest Endpoints und sonst was. Das
war ein Riesenakt ja. Also ich rede jetzt von Updates vom Server zum Client. Wenn der
Client irgendwas hat, dann sind manchmal 2-3 Endpoints auch nicht verkehrt. Also GraphQL
mit Subscriptions ist ja eher dafür, wenn sich auf dem Server was geändert hat, was
man zum Client pushen will, wenn der Client jetzt ein Button gedrückt hat für Drucken
oder so, dann war das nix mit GraphQL-Subscriptions zu tun. Dann muss man irgendeinen Get-Request
machen. Ja, das habe ich auch letztens erst in einem Video gesehen, habe ich mich noch
nicht mit beschäftigt. Fast Endpoints ist ja quasi die Geschichte für ASP.NET Core,
weil man keinen Bock hat MVC, also Model-View-Controller zu machen, sondern Minimal-APs ein bisschen
aufbauen will. So, wir fangen jetzt mal an. Es ist 2.15 Uhr, mal gucken, ob wir was auf
die Reihe kriegen heute. Wir machen mal einen neuen Ordner. Repos-MKdir. Leute, wir brauchen
einen guten Namen für das Projekt. Ich dachte mir, ich nenne es Label-Champ, aber vielleicht
habt ihr bessere Ideen. Jett, irgendwelche...Dymo-Champ? Ja, es ist prinzipiell am Ende ja nur für
Dymosachen, wobei Potenziales für alles funktionieren könnte. Deswegen fände ich Label-Champ vielleicht
besser. Battleship, weißt du, was ich mache in letzter Zeit? Ich finde die Funktion von
12Kit ganz cool. Zum Beispiel, dass du diesen File-Based-Router hast und sowas. Ich mache
überhaupt kein Server-Site-Rendering. Das erste, was ich in 12Kit mache, ist Server-Site-Rendering
ausschalten. Das ist einfach alles kleint rendern. Aber halt die Sachen, die ganz nice
sind, trotzdem weiterverwenden. X the Labeler. Das ist nice, das gefällt mir. Aber es versteht
keiner. Drucker-Champ, Dymo-Champ, Label-Champ. Label mich nicht voll. Ok Label-Champ, ich
bleibe bei Label-Champ. Schreibt man Label eigentlich so oder so? Ne, so oder? Nicht
Label. Das ist ja auch der Unterschied zwischen Angel und Angel. Ah, Angel does it again.
US oder UK? Wirklich? UK sagt Label? Ne, oder? Fuck. Wirklich? Oh nein. Please. Englisch
ist ja auch ein richtiger Painz-Champ. Ich meine, die Amis sind sich noch nicht mal bei
ihren Einheiten einig intern. Wenn jetzt noch UK-Englisch und alles dabei kommt, irgendwann
kommt auch die Australier. Oi. Dann ist vorbei. Mate. Oi Mate. Die Australier sagen ja zur
Begrüßung G'day. Ich kann das gar nicht aussprechen. G'day. G'day. An jeder Soz
eins. Ok. Label. Der Label-Champ. G'day. G'day gleich Moin. Sowas in der Richtung.
Also, jetzt. Wir bauen jetzt mal ganz schnell so Minimal-Prototyp, dass man sieht, was ich
vorhabe, ja. Also, machen wir mal ein Ordner. MK-Dear-Backend. Das mach ich einfach mal
for future use. Ich hab noch, ich hab noch kein Backend. Das löschen wir gleich wieder.
Svelte-Kit. So. Ich kann's mir nicht merken. Ah ja, da. Da sind wir. Ok. Yes. Proceed.
Wir Proceeden. This is Beta-Software. Sagt mal. Wann gibt es eigentlich Svelte-Kit? Version
eins. Irgendwann. Schaffen die das irgendwann mal? Version. Gibt keine Version. Text. 1.0.0.
Next. 3.1.4. Alles klar. Da weißt du Bescheid. Frontend-Backend. Beste Ordner. Ja, und wissen
ihr, wisst ihr, was das, was das Beste daran ist? Pass mal auf. Eigentlich, eigentlich
müsste ich das anders nennen. Sekunde. Sekunde, Leute. Ich, ich hab mich vertan. Eigentlich
müsste ich das anders nennen und zwar. Nein, nein. Eigentlich, eigentlich müsste ich das
Web nennen, weil es könnte ja sein, dass wir auch noch ein Desktop-Frontend machen,
was ja, was nicht wahrscheinlich ist. No, no, no, no, no. So. Und wisst ihr, was das
coole ist? Wenn ihr sowas macht, könnt ihr auf den aktuellen Hype-Zug aufspringen. Chris
B., schön, dass du deinen Weg her gefunden hast. Ich hab was gelesen von dir bisher.
Ähm, also. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Ja, ihr könnt jetzt, ihr könnt jetzt, ihr könnt
jetzt auch auf den, auf den aktuellen Hype-Train aufspringen, sobald ihr Backend und Frontend
im gleichen Repo liegen habt, Leute. Frage an den Chat. Welches Hype-Buzzword könnte
man damit jetzt verwenden? Monorepo. Richtig Beizteig. Monorepo. Wir haben jetzt Backend
und Web-Frontend im gleichen, im gleichen Ordner liegen. Monorepo, Leute. Ich sag's
euch. Macht einfach, bist du eingestellt? Ich würde dich sofort einstellen. Ich hab
bloß keine freien Stellen, um jemand einzustellen. Ähm, Monorepo. Genau, Monorepo ist zurzeit
voll angesagt. Ihr packt einfach jetzt alles, was ihr früher schön gesplittet habt, dass
es übersichtlicher ist, in ein Repo und dann sagt ihr Monorepo. Ein Anti-Micro-Service.
Nee, nee. Das können trotzdem unterschiedliche Sachen voneinander sein. Also, zum Beispiel,
man hätte jetzt, sagen wir mal, ähm, was weiß ich, einen Service für, ähm, Background-Newsletter
verschicken, ja. Man hätte noch einen Service für, ähm, Userverwaltung, man hätte noch
einen Service, der das Web-Frontend surft und sowas. Dann würde man hier drei Ordner
drinne machen und würde alles ins gleiche Repo packen und dann nennt man das ganz cool
Monorepo. Ja, wenn Neuklonen den ganzen Tag dauern sollen. Richtig. Wie wird ein Monorepo
agil? Allein schon, dass Monorepo ein aktuelles Passwort ist, ist das automatisch agil. Das
ist doch dumm, ne? Ja, das ist mo... Hä, was heißt? Monorepo ist halt voll angesagt
aktuell. Jeder, der cool ist, macht Monorepos. Guck mal, Monorepo. Was sagt denn Wikipedia
das? Ich mein, guck mal, wenn das Google, Facebook, Microsoft, Uber, Airbnb und Twitter
macht, dann muss das geil sein. Code for many projects is stored in the same repository.
Dann muss das gut sein, wenn die das machen. Ganz ehrlich, ich, ich kann der Idee tatsächlich
was abgewinnen. Je nachdem, wie groß der ganze Kram ist. Ich kann, ich kann der Idee tatsächlich
was abgewinnen, weil ich bin auch jemand, der, sag mal, lieber vielleicht die Methode
und die Funktion ein bisschen länger macht, als das, was irgendwie normalerweise so als
hübsch angesehen wird. Aber nur dann, also nicht so wie ich es im Stream mache, im Stream
ist es immer mega eklig, was ich bastle, aber ok, das, anderes Thema werden wir gleich sehen,
aber nur, wenn das thematisch zueinander passt. Ja, ich find's immer richtig ätzend, wenn
ich mir Source Code durchlesen muss und der Typ, was weiß ich, du findest irgendeine
Funktion, die was macht. Da drin werden dann erstmal 18 weitere Funktionen aufgerufen
und die sind halt alle nur 3, 4, 5 Zeilen lang, aber du musst dich durch Gott und die Welt
durchklicken und dir im Kopf überlegen, was callt jetzt was, von wo callt es nun und wo
callt es jetzt wieder. Anstatt, dass du einfach, anstatt über 18 Funktionen verteilt mit jeweils
5 Zeilen, ja, dann hast du halt mal eine, wenn es ein bisschen komplexer ist, Funktion oder
Methode mit, lass es mal 100 Zeilen sein, das ist dann schon zwar grenzwertig, wo sich
viele sagen würden, das würde ich nicht machen, aber wenn das dazu führt, dass die Sachen,
die zusammen gehören, zusammen stehen, finde ich das nicht verkehrt. Wenn du den Kram natürlich
aufplättest, weil du es an anderen Stellen wieder verwenden kannst oder weil du es an
anderen Stellen nochmal brauchst, dann ist das was anderes, aber einfach nur 20 Funktionen
machen, obwohl die nur an einer Stelle gebraucht werden, anstatt untereinander zu schreiben,
dann hast du vielleicht dich an irgendwelche Conference Talk Best Practice Sachen gehalten,
weil du sagen kannst, ach guck mal, nix ist länger als 20 Zeilen und was auch immer, nur
dass du am Ende nicht mehr durchblickst, wie der genaue Fluss ist. Das würde voll gegen
unseren Style Guide gehen, ja. Ich finde es trotzdem sinnvoll, ich weiß, dass das gegen
viele Style Guides geht, aber ich finde das durchaus sinnvoll, Sachen, die zusammen gehören,
zusammen hinzuschreiben, sofern man sie eben nur da braucht. Ähm, ich verwende den nicht
mehr. Ich habe die letzten paar Monate meinen Staubsauger nicht mehr laufen gehabt. Ja,
Beidstrack, sagst du recht, am besten ist natürlich, wenn du einen anderen Ansatz findest,
der kürzer geht. Aber manche Sachen sind halt nunmal irgendwie komplex. Man muss es
ja nicht übertreiben, wie irgendwelche C++ Klassen, die ausgedruckt acht Seiten lang
sind. In Fußballfeldern. In Deutschland messen wir die Sachen, musst du alles in Fußballfeldern
messen. In was messen die Amis eigentlich? Was haben die denn? Baseballfelder oder Basketballcourts
oder? Was haben die denn so für Standardvergleichsdinger? Trucks? In Trucks? Nein, ich meine, was ist
das Ami Gegenstück zu unserer Marseinheit Fußballfeld? Bei uns wird ja alles immer
in Fußballfeldern, oder oftmals in Fußballfeldern. Pickup-Size? Baseballfeld, machen die sowas?
Ounces pro Meils. Ja, das draufsteht tatsächlich zu, wo wir gerade dabei sind. Wisst ihr, was
die beste Einheit der Welt ist? Wenn ihr mal wirklich Abfrag-Einheiten haben wollt, dann
guckt euch mal an, British Thermal Unit pro Stunde. Und allein schon wenn man sich das
durchliest, erkennt man, dass ist wirklich Abfrag, ja? Das ist eine Einheit, ihre Einheit
ist, also, hier. Ein BTU ist definiert als die Wärmeenergie, die benötigt wird, um
ein britisches Pfund Wasser um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erwärmen. Also da ist vorbei. Das ist,
da ist wirklich durch. Das benutzen die teilweise heute noch. Also das ist wirklich ganz schlimm.
Wo wir gerade, wo wir gerade bei, bei so Einheiten sind, was ich auch immer geil finde ist, wenn
die Leute sagen, wat, alter, wenn die Leute sagen, wat pro Sekunde, ja? Ich mein man
sagt ja KMH und da denken die Leute dann sowas wie KWH ist halt quasi auch wat durch Zeit,
was hier nicht stimmt. Es ist mal, es ist mal. Das ist wat mal Sekunde, also da steht ein
mal dazwischen. Das ist nicht wie Kilometer durch Stunde, sondern es ist mal, weil das
ist eine Menge. Weil man muss sich immer überlegen, dass in wat eigentlich ja schon, zumindest
wenn man sich mal so das klassische anguckt von Joules pro Sekunde, schon die Zeit mit
drinne steckt. Also ergibt es gar keinen Sinn zu sagen, durch Sekunde, durch Sekunde wäre
eher so ein Anstieg oder sowas, wenn du quasi sagst, irgendwie die Leistung steigt pro Sekunde
so und so viel, irgendwie sowas, aber ja. Aber ich verstehe es, dass das hier viele
Leute Gürschnaller bringen, eben mit Kilometer pro Stunde und die denken dann Kilowattstunde
und dann muss das auch ein Durch sein und so. Alternativ könnte man das auch in PTU angeben.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, das hat es wahrscheinlich von Wikipedia, aber daran
sieht man das auch schon mal. Daran sieht man das auch schon mal, dass da pro Stunde
ist eine Einheit ohne explizite Zeitangabe. Also daran sieht man, da steckt die Zeit schon
mit drinne in der Einheit. Richtig, richtig. Klassisch ist das Joules pro Sekunde und man
hat das dann einfach umbenannt in diese Einheit. Da steckt die Zeit schon mit drin, deswegen
pro Sekunde blöd das zu sagen. So, wie auch immer wir jetzt draufgekommen sind. So, also
wir kriegen heute wahrscheinlich nichts mehr auf die Reihe. Mein Backend, wir machen gar
kein Backend jetzt, wir machen nur Frontend aktuell. Das Backend machen wir mit wieder
ASP.com vielleicht, vielleicht brauchen wir auch noch einen Tick Null.js dabei, da bin
ich mir noch nicht so ganz sicher. Also, Web, wir machen erstmal npm install, weil sonst
funktioniert wahrscheinlich nix. Nee, ein Go Backend machen wir nicht, keck wait, alter.
Go. Go hat jetzt Generics. Hat schon jemand mal Go mit Generics verwendet seit der letzten
Version? Haben die das gescheit gemacht oder ist das wieder irgendwie sowas, wo man sich
fragt, warum muss es so kompliziert sein? So wie zum Beispiel, dass Go gerne schleifen
macht anstatt ordentliche Extensions für Listen und Dictionaries zu bieten. Ja, Go macht
lieber 3 nested vorschleifen anstatt ein Select oder Filter oder sowas. So, starten wir mal
Minus Minus Open. So, da, SvelteKit Start App. Perfekt, achso wir müssen Visual Studio Code
erstmal aufmachen. So, da, Open, da. Yes, wir trusten. Massive SvelteKit App. So, Source,
Grau. Was passiert denn jetzt gerade? Platform IO. Nein, ich brauch jetzt kein Arduino Zeug,
geh mal fort. Wer braucht Go? QBasic reicht schon. QBasic. Ist QBasic, war QBasic nicht
der Krampel von Microsoft, den sie damals sogar mit Windows ausgeliefert haben? Ich
erinnere mich dran, dunkel, dass ich damit, wo ich klein war mal irgendwas gemacht habe.
Spazierengehen um 20.37 Uhr. Spazierengehen oder Spazierengehen? Ist die Frage, was damit
umschrieben werden soll. Also ich muss es neu starten, ok, ich muss es neu starten,
weil was auch immer. So, gut. Routes, Index, so der ganze Krampel kommt weg. So, jetzt
machen wir noch ein paar. Ok. Add. Tailwind. Bisschen CSS Magic. Yes, proceed. NPM install.
Gleich wieder CSS Skills, ja das wird grausam, ich sag's euch Leute. Ok, haben wir jetzt
alles? Wahrscheinlich. Ich mach das nochmal doppelt auf. Open. Alles klar. So. Huge CSS
Skills, genau. Also wir machen erstmal das Ding heißt Label Champ. Das heißt das erste
was wir brauchen ist eine Leiste oben. Einfach weil's funktioniert. Label Champ, sehr schön.
Was machen wir hier? H3. Texts. XL. Label Champ in groß. XXL. XXXL. Zwei mal XL. Naja,
3 mal XL. Label Champ muss herausstechen, ja. Text, bold, ne font. Font, bold, CSS. Der
Label Champ, da isser. Perfekt. Erklär mal was du machst, ich mach ne Webseite. Und den
Rest, das andere wird man gleich sehen. Da bin ich mir selbst noch nicht ganz sicher.
So, also jetzt brauchen wir Hintergrund. Leute, gute Idee für den Hintergrund. Gray. 900.
Oh ja, das ist gut. Das ist der perfekte Hintergrund. Da sieht man auch alles. Sehr gut zu lesen.
Perfekt. Also ich würd sagen, das ist wirklich, Usability und so ist schon mal ganz weit
oben jetzt. Ne, was war das? Texts, white. Vielleicht nicht white, sondern 100. 100 oder
vielleicht sogar 100. Scheiß drauf. Es hat nichts. Nicht damit aufhalten, ja. Wir können
es doch einfach blau machen. Weil wir machen es. Texts, Indigo. Irgendwie so. Alter, das
sieht mega hässlich aus. Das sieht super beschissen aus. Das sieht super, das sieht
mega beschissen aus. Ich mach jetzt einfach weiter. Ich halt mich jetzt nicht mit irgendwelchem
komischen Krempel auf. Also, der Label Champ ist am Start. Okay. So. Und jetzt ConvertJS.
Hab ich noch nie verwendet. Tutorial. Also damit kann man Sachen malen auf sein. Hier
machen wir mal Circle. So. Da kann man dann so Dinger auf sein Canvas malen. Und das kann
man dann auch rumschieben und sowas. Und dann machen wir Text und QR Codes und Material
Design Icons und sowas zum Reintracken und Droppen oder zum Anklicken. Und dann kann
man ein geiles Label hier designen. Gucken wie easy das zu verwenden ist. Also, wie installiert
man das? GitHub. Conver. Install. NPM. NPM install. Conver. Ich hab bis heute nicht gecheckt,
was das Minus Minus Save macht. Ich bin halt einfach Frontend. Frontend Noob. Lull. So.
Und wie geht das jetzt weiter? Import Conver. From Conver. Okay. Script. Ich hasse Frontend
Stills. Ich machs eigentlich auch nicht gerne. So. Also, wie funktioniert das jetzt? Var
with Height Stage Container. Copy Paste das einfach mal. Wir machen mal das. Was? Could
not find Container Element. Achso. Div. Wahrscheinlich ID. Container oder so. OKS. Muss ich vielleicht
mal neu starten? NPM install. Hab ich irgendwas? Moment, ich muss mir das mal angucken. Mach
ich da irgendwas falsch? Nö. Ach, ich weiß woran das liegt. Wahrscheinlich ist das Element
noch gar nicht geladen. Was? Cannot find Package Canvas? Node? Moment, warum importiert
der Node? Das ist doch schonmal... Hä? Was? Wo ist das Problem? Was hat der für Schmerz?
Ach, das ist weil ich Server Site Rendering nicht ausgeschaltet hab. Ich kack Noob. Moment
Leute, ich muss Server Site Rendering ausschalten. Lull. Das Copy Paste ich mir gleich. Ich glaub
Source File Hooks.js. Und jetzt wird Copy Paste. Das hab ich mir schon gemerkt, weil ich das
immer brauch. Server Site Rendering muss aus. Der versucht gerade Server seitlich das Canvas
zu rendern und das kann natürlich nicht funktionieren. Cannot find Container. OK, jetzt brauch ich
Swell Mount. On Mount. Funktion ist nämlich nicht. On Mount. Also sprich, der versucht
jetzt das Element anzusprechen, was noch gar nicht geladen ist, weil die Seite noch nicht
fertig geladen ist. Also On Mount. On Mount. Ja, das sieht doch schon besser aus. OK, wie
geht das Beispiel weiter? Layer, Circle, Add Circle. OK, das ist easy as fuck. Also wenn
ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht hab, sollte ich jetzt einen roten Kreis mit schwarzem Rand
bekommen. Kunst, easy. So. Track. Track and drop. To track and drop, Chef, we can track,
trackable, track, trackable, track, trackable, true. Boah, guck mal hier. Es moved. Massive
moving. Huge, huge, huge, huge ke move. Guck mal da. Da muss man sagen, das ist aber einfach.
Also sowas. Normalerweise müssen wir noch viel ekliche Events handeln in JavaScript,
dass das funzt. Frage, was ist ein Dymo Etikettendrucker, sowas hier. Labelwriter 450, sowas. Ein Etikettendrucker.
Ist das das neue P5? Ne. So, also so macht man schonmal Kreise. So und wie? Resize, haben
die auch was dazu. Resize, select, transform, select, ne. Basic, Basic Demo. Ahja, hier
guck mal. Das, sowas, sowas will ich machen. Sowas will ich machen. Wie geht das? Layer,
Text, Transformer. Äh, was? Ok, jetzt wirds, jetzt wirds, jetzt wirds advanced hier. Also,
Moment, Moment. Th1, Nodes, Circle soll selected sein. Wie das alles? Ok, das ist easy. Aber
das Center Scaling ist doof, das soll gefällig sein. Ja, das finde ich gut. Guck mal, easy.
Diagonal skalieren und wenn man hier macht. Guck mal, das muss man alles nicht selbst
programmieren, das finde ich schonmal nice. Das ist easy. Draw, I, O, Embedden funktioniert
nicht gescheit. Das hab ich ausprobiert. Das musst du als iframe embedden und die API
zum kommunizieren mit Draw, I, O ist äußerst minimalistisch. Was wir passieren, wir machen
eine Web Anwendung, wo man für einen Label Drucker sich Label zusammenbauen kann. Ach
so, Moment, wie mach ich denn jetzt entfernen? Ich möchte, ich möchte entfernen das ganze
jetzt. Events, woah, Events. Doch, ich kanns lokal auf dem Webserver ausliefern, aber
da muss ichs auch als iframe embedden. Oder ich integriere es irgendwie in meine Seite,
muss lernen, wie man das bedient so richtig. Nee, das ist. ConvertJS Keyboard Events, Keyboard
Events will ich haben. Listen Global Events on Window Object. Ja, Window Object soll mir
recht sein. Also, Svelte, Window, On, Key, Down, Handle, Key. Ja, heißt einfach so.
Key, Keydown. Ach nee, das muss man in Klammern schreiben, dass das geht, gell. Ja, ok. Funktion.
JavaScript, Handle, Keydown. Event. Man darf es ja nicht Event nennen, weil das reserviert
ist in JavaScript oder darf man es doch Event nennen? Ok, anscheinend darf man es doch
Event nennen. Ich dachte Event ist reserviertes Keyword in JavaScript. So, und wenn ich jetzt
ne Taste drück, dann Keyboard Event. Jawoll. Ok, Delete und Backspace. Also, wie löscht
man den Kram jetzt? Erstmal brauch ich das wahrscheinlich als globale Variable denke
ich mal. Stage, Layer oder wie nenne ich das denn? Layer, keine Ahnung und was haben wir
sonst noch? Nix mehr. Ah, vielleicht noch Selection oder sowas. Warum sind das überhaupt
wahr? Also Stage, Let, Let, Layer, Circle, das heißt Selection, Add. So, und jetzt guck
ich einfach, ob ich die Taste drücke. If, Event, Key, Gleich, Gleich, Delete. So, und
dann sag ich Selection. Tja, Selection, was, wie. Woher weiß ich was, was Selected wurde?
Woher, woher weiß ich jetzt was das Ding? Macht die Let Variablen zusammen irgendein
Objekt? Ja, ist wahrscheinlich Sinn, Sinn egal. Ähm. Moment, ich bin bei Keyboard Events,
da will ich gar nicht hin. Scaling. Ich will eigentlich den Kram haben, wie man den, wie
das ist hier TR1. Nodes? Nodes? Nodes? Gibt sowas? Selection, Nodes? Heißt das so? Circle,
ah tatsächlich, easy. So, und jetzt Conver, Delete, Shape. How to Delete Shape? Ah, Destroy.
Oder kann man? Alles was Selected ist automatisch. Selected, Destroy. Geht das? Äh, nee. Also
Nodes, aber eine Schleife, oder? For Each, Shape und jetzt Destroy. Zack, eh. Lul. Das
ist immer noch Selected. Das sollte es aber nicht sein. Also muss ich wahrscheinlich trotzdem
noch sagen, Selection, Nodes und dann einfach Leer. Zack und ich kann den Kram schon wieder
löschen. Komm mal her, ich kann den Kram Rotaten, ich kann den Kram Rescalen und ich
kann den Kram löschen mit dem Entferntaste. Das ist doch schon mal nice. Oder, oder, Event,
Key, gleich, gleich, Backspace. Backspace, nice. Zack. Ok, die Basics, die Basics für
einen Image Editor sind schon mal da. Mal eine Programmierfrage, wo brauche ich rekreusive
Methoden, außer bei Fakultät hast du ein Beispiel. Nicht oft. Ich glaube ich hab, was
hab ich, ich hab in letzter Zeit zwei Sachen, lass mal kurz in mich gehen. Was hab ich denn
probiert, was war das denn? Irgendwas zusammenrechnen war das, wo das ganz nice funktioniert hat.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was ich machen wollte. Am Ende wollte ich irgendwas zusammenrechnen,
das weiß ich noch. Ach, keine Ahnung. Aber ganz ehrlich, die meisten Sachen sind, sind
abfuck kompliziert rekreusiv. Zwischenergebnisse in irgendwelche Listen packen ist meistens
für das Gehirn einfacher zu verstehen. Zumindest für meins. Gibt es eigentlich, das können
jetzt die ganzen Informatik-Studenten erzählen, gibt es denn eigentlich irgendwelche Algorithmen
oder Sachen, die man nur, also die man bewiesenermaßen nur rekreusiv machen kann und nicht iterativ.
Also wohlgemerkt, Listen, Stacks und sowas sind erlaubt. Du kannst ja den Kram dir quasi
immer zwischenspeichern in irgendeiner Que oder sowas. Aha, der Chat weiß Bescheid, die
Ackermann-Funktion. Das hat aber bestimmt nichts mit dem ehemaligen Telekom-Typ zu
tun. So, und jetzt, Leute, wir machen jetzt mal was für den Show-Effekt, Leute. Wir fangen
jetzt mal mit etwas Interessantem an. Mit was wollen wir anfangen? QR-Code einfügen
oder Image-Copypasten? QR-Code? Aber mach mal QR-Code. Image. Ja, wir machen beides.
Nee, keine Abstimmung. Wir machen jetzt QR-Code zuerst und danach das Bild. So. Übrigens
kennt ihr, oder wie die heißen? Kennt ihr diesen Editor? Das ist was, wo ein paar YouTube-Leute
und sowas früher Thumbnails mitgemacht haben. Und ich werde jetzt ganz schamlos dieses
UI ein bisschen klauen von denen. Guck, da hast du hier Elemente, die du reintracken
und droppen kannst und sowas. Ich mein, so sophistik hältet für die, wie die, werde
ich das definitiv nicht machen, ja. Das ist schon mal klar. Aber ich glaube, ich werde
das UI ein bisschen klauen von denen für die Geschichte. Guck mal, die haben doch nicht
mal QR-Codes. Wir haben was, was die nicht haben. So. Aber ich mach auch hier unten jetzt
noch eine Zeile rein. Hier. Diff. QR-Q. Ich mach hier unten noch eine Zeile rein. Die
so Menü, Menü-Einträge hat. Ok. Material Design Icons. Was nennen wir denn da? If-Schleifen,
der Chat geht wieder ab. Also wir fangen an mit QR-Codes. Wir brauchen ein schönes
Icon für QR-Codes. Das da. Exzellent. Ne, wir machen ein Plus. Weil wir fügen, wir fügen
das ja hinzu. Wobei, das ist ein schöneres Icon. Als SVG. Gib her. Also. Ok. Class. Fulle
Breite. Fulle Breite. Fixed Positioning. Fixed oder Static? Was ist der Unterschied
zwischen Fixed und Static? Irgendwelche CSS-Cracks und Fifehead-Leute am Start. Bottom Zero. BG,
was haben wir hier oben genommen? BG. Cray. 900. Ok. Hübsch ist es net. Nice. So und
der Text, der Text ist dann Text Cray 200. So. Und da soll es nicht QAQW rein, sondern
Button mit einem SVG drinnen. Sehr schön. Guck mal. John Hammer. Kann man das ein bisschen
kleiner machen? Kann man nicht sagen. Höhe. Leute. Die HTML-Kennner. Die HTML-Kennner.
Also Window Inner Height ist nicht nur dieses Ding, sondern das gesamte Fenster. Was, was
ist das? Ist das vielleicht Document oder so? Ne. Wie bekomme ich denn die Höhe raus
nur von diesem Ding? Ohne die, ohne die Dev-Tools? Jemanden planen, ob das funktioniert? Wie
das geht? Ich frage, ich frage Stack Overflow. Ne. View-High geht nicht. Document Body Inner
Height. Ah. Exzellent, exzellent. Der Chat ist wieder. Document Body Inner Height. Ne.
Offset. Ne. Das funktioniert nicht. Without Dev-Tools. Ok. Ok. Einfach nur. Höhe. Ok.
Das gibt's. Oh, ist das jQuery? Ah. E. JQuery. MonkaS. Weg. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Was? Ja, aber das hat, das funktioniert doch nicht. Das funktioniert doch nicht, das ist
nur so hoch. Ach, muss ich vielleicht, muss ich vielleicht beim Container jetzt angeben?
Class 100% oder so? Ne. Wird das denn größer, wenn ich sowas angehe? Ok, das geht prinzipiell.
Screen. Ne. Das ist unten auch dabei. Mensch. Ist das 100%? Ist ne gute Frage. Ne, wahrscheinlich
nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist mein Body-Tag nicht 100%. Body. Also. Class. Body. Volle Breite.
Volle Höhe. Ist ihm aber auch egal. Ok, Quaid. Alter, ich bin zu unfähig, was CSS-Kram angeht.
Es ist scheiß drauf. Wir machen das. Das ist zu lang, wo wir jetzt damit rumwurschteln.
Ich bleib jetzt dabei. Ich mein, das ist jetzt zum Ausprobieren erstmal nicht das Problem.
Body-Kleinheit. Ne, das ist es nicht. Oh ja, guck mal, guck mal. Document. Body. Ne, 48
ist das nur. Was auch immer. Ich lasse, ich lasse es jetzt so. Damit kann ich leben. Svelte,
Bindheit. Ja, das ist das gleiche, was ich hier auslese. Das wird es nicht sein. Ok.
Also. Wir haben jetzt ein Icon. Das sieht nicht schön aus. Also erstmal Flex. Das sieht schon
mal besser aus. Immer flexen. Höhe 12. Oder 14. 12. So, jetzt müssen wir mit dem Icon
vielleicht noch ein bisschen was... Was ist denn ein schöner Hintergrund für diese Icons,
dass man die erkennt. Glas. BG. Grün. Ich hätte jetzt eher an sowas gedacht. Aber
ne, hast recht. Vielleicht können wir es mal ausprobieren. Emeralds. Na, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht. Ne. Warum ist das so kacke ausgerichtet? Ist das nicht groß genug? Ah,
das ist nicht groß genug. So. Teal. Teal. Bisschen dunkler. Ich weiß nicht, so schön
finde ich das ehrlich gesagt nicht. Pink. Ich finde das ist gar nicht mal übel. Leute,
ich muss... Ich finde das sieht mit Pink sogar gar nicht mal übel aus. Magenta. Ja. So.
Ich brauche im Prinzip ja nur den Button. So und jetzt. Hover. BG. Pink. 600. Ok. So.
Wunderbar. Oder vielleicht was blaues Leute. Irgendwas blaues. Ach egal wir lassen es
jetzt so. Ok. Click. On. Click. Insert. QR-Code. Und jetzt ist die große Frage. Ich brauche
eine gute QR-Code Library. Orange. Ok. Function. Insert. QR-Code. Wir müssen dann irgendwie
den Text eingeben oder so. Aber wir lassen jetzt erstmal den Standard. Test. Test. Text.
Orange. Der Chat sagt Orange. Orange. Leute Orange oder Pink? Ehrlich gesagt die Dinger
da unten können ruhig ein bisschen unauffälliger sein. Ich lasse es jetzt mal so. Es ist ja
wirklich nur zum testen ob man da drauf klicken kann dann was passiert. Pink. Copper Pride
Chat wieder am Start. Telekommagenta RGB. Ne ne. Ich brauche kein. Ich. Ich brauche
kein Bash QR-Code Generator. Ich brauche ein JavaScript QR-Code Generator. Ok. Insert
QR. GitHub. QR. Code. JS. QR. Warum sind die genauso einfallslos wie ich? Warum heißt
es auch noch QR-Code JS? Ah Moment. Generator. Generator brauchen wir. Ne. Vor sieben Jahren
das verwende ich nicht. QR-Code. Wir suchen jetzt mal bei GitHub. QR-Code. Und jetzt
languages. Alter 3651 QR-Code JavaScript. Node QR-Code. Das klingt doch gut. Easy QR-Code
JS. Feature rich cross browser pure JavaScript generation library. Der Text ist schon so
krass hier. Und die ReadMe ist schon so viel. Was zum. MonkaS. Basic Usage. Ne ich würde
das ungern ungern direkt in ein Element rendern. Ich hätte das lieber als Bild was ich dann
auf mein Canvas adden kann. Als Konver Element. Kann das nicht als SVG oder sowas? Stand doch
irgendwie sowas gerade. Alter. Ich will einfach nur ein QR-Code. Ich will das nicht studieren.
WTF. Alter. SVG. Ne. PNG. OG.
Das ist mir zu kompliziert. Wie sieht denn das andere aus? Reading Library. Node QR-Code.
QR-Code SVG sagt der Chat. Okay. Svelte QR-Code. Das bringt mir nix. Ich glaube Svelte Library
bringt mir nix. Weil ich muss das ja eh dann selbst malen. In dem Canvas. Das bringt mir
leider nix. GitHub. Poor. Wir hatten das gerade gepostet im Chat. Bist du der Library Autor?
Der das Freund gepostet hat? Vor zwei Jahren. Okay. SVG Node. Ja ich ich brauch's. Ich ich
brauch das als PNG wahrscheinlich. QR-Message. Ich mach das jetzt damit. Das hat viele Sterne.
Das muss was taugen. NPM in Minus G. Nein nein bestimmt nicht Minus G. QR-Code. So und jetzt
Import. Import QR-Code. Ja sowas brauche ich. To data URL. Genau sowas ist gut. Sowas ist gut
als PNG wenn es geht. Okay. QR-Code. Lässt sich schon mal importieren. So und jetzt await
QR-Code to data URL. Alles klar. Also insert QR-Code. Schauen wir mal ob das prinzipiell
tut. Text. Der Text ist keqw größer. Nein das ist falsch rum. Lul. Lul wie größer keqw.
Async. Okay das scheint zu funktionieren. Guck mal da ist der QR-Code. Nice. Also Generating
funktioniert schon mal. Jetzt ist die Frage wie man das insertet. Conver insert data URL
Canvas to data URL. Class Image. Import Image oder sowas. Image. How to drop image elements.
Image. Image. New Image. Hier. New Conver Image. Image Object. Image Object ist das. New Image.
Ach guck mal. From URL. Geht das auch wenn ich das so mache? Okay das testen wir jetzt
mal. Also. So QR-Code. Also das hier ist der QR-Code der generiert wird. Also das das
das. Die diese data. Data URL. So und jetzt. From URL. Code. Callback. Ich hätte eigentlich
gedacht da kommt jetzt ein Image raus aber anscheinend nicht. Und dadurch kann ich es
erwarten. Ne. Svoid. Svoid das geht nicht. Callback. Warum welcher Callback Funktion.
Ach hier edit der das dann drin. Okay. Also das ist dann quasi das Image. Wenn es das
gepasst hat oder was auch immer. Und jetzt sage ich layer add. Image. Einfach so. Das
wäre easy. Ha. Das ist einfach. Easy. So und wie mache ich das jetzt? Ah Moment ich will
das noch machen. Image. Track. Trackable. Trackable. Image. Image. Track. Hallo ich
will ich will die API vom vom Image haben. Image. Track. Trackable. True. True. Lulwee.
Easy Leute. Ah guck mal das hat einen Hintergrund. Das soll kein Hintergrund haben. Das soll
kein Hintergrund haben. Wie mache ich den Hintergrund weg? Äh weg. Ne das ist ein anderes
Package. Wo ist. Ah. NordQrCode. Du hast gescannt das Funktion. Ach hier guck mal. Color.
Also. Ne da jetzt? Obz. So. Ha. Guck mal der Hintergrund ist weg. Pogchamp. Aber vielleicht
nicht. Vielleicht nicht in blau. Schwarz ist schon in Ordnung was das angeht. Ja. Was
ist das? Image. Background. False. Das geht auch. Schauen wir mal. API. Image. Background.
Background. Ne. Ne das gibt es nicht. Ich werde jebaited. Captain Peng. War geraten.
Nice. Guck mal das ist ja easy. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Also wir müssen uns natürlich
auch damit beschäftigen. Wie kriege ich die Selection bei einem Klick hin und sowas.
Der Printer kann nur schwarz weiß. Ja das ist richtig. Also dass das hier in rot ist
ist total bescheuert. Das sollten wir vielleicht gleich nochmal. In irgendeinen Grauton packen
oder so. Grey. Oder Grey. Das Schlimme ist das beides geht HTML technisch. Ja der kann
nur schwarz weiß der Label Drucker. So wie machen wir das denn mit Selection. Ich brauche
irgendwie sowas Maus down oder sowas. Wie mache ich das mit Selection. Ok. Conver select
Maus down. Gibt es da irgendein Event für? Shape Events. Stage. On. Maus move. Gibt
es nicht sowas wie on Maus down oder so. Kann man nicht einfach auf der Stage sowas
machen. Stage. On. Maus. Ist Maus down das richtige oder ist es Maus click oder sowas.
Event. Lock Event. Ne das ist Maus down. Ach guck mal. Target. Stage. Target. Circle.
Also das heißt im Prinzip muss ich jetzt gucken. So let target gleich Event. Target. Gibt es
dieses Event auch ohne Target wahrscheinlich nicht. So das habe ich bei den tollen auf
der Webseite gesehen ich erinnere mich. Er musste gucken ist das Target das da dann macht
man nichts. Ne dann macht man unselect alles. Also Selection. Nodes. Leer. So das heißt
wenn ich jetzt auf die Stage klicke unselectet der alles. So und jetzt anderweitig gibt
es Selection. Nodes. Target. Guck mal. Easy. Easy. Seht ihr das. Poggers. Und wenn ich
raus klicke ist weg. Guck mal und das geilste ist ich kann das. Was jetzt. Warum kackt das
jetzt ab. Wenn ich. Ach wahrscheinlich ist das Maus down. Wahrscheinlich wird das Maus
down auch für resize verwendet. Was. Was macht man da jetzt. Also was was können wir.
Was können wir denn dagegen machen. Vielleicht muss ich checken. Dass das meine. Oh fuck
meine Elemente sind. Also sowas wie. If. Target. Gleich gleich. Type of geht das in
Javascript. Circle. Circle. Javascript Profis geht sowas. Irgendwie. Type of.
Blubber. Was. Also. Also so. Nee.
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung wie ich das mache. Teste ob Target in der Selection drin ist.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Das ist tatsächlich. Nee. Nee. Target in der Selection bringt
nichts ich will es ja erst selekten. Instance of Circle. Alter Javascript man. Insta. Das
gibt es tatsächlich. Was ist denn das was habe ich noch nie verwendet. Hey es funktioniert
wieder. Guck mal. Pog. Chat. Massive. Freifährt. Aber gut das trifft ja. Moment. Das geht
das nur für Circles. Das geht nur für Circles. Das stimmt ja nicht. Das geht es für meinen
QR Code nicht mehr. Wie kann ich denn jetzt. Checken dass es nicht abkackt. Wie check
ich denn jetzt dass es. Also ich weiß gar nicht warum es überhaupt abkackt ehrlich gesagt.
Warum kackt es. Warum kackt es denn überhaupt ab. Was. Also was. Was ist. Was hat er eigentlich
für. Beschmerzen. Ach so du. Jetzt verstehe ich was du meinst. Du meinst. Jetzt die Selection.
Checken. Ach so. Ja das könnte ich mal an Selection. Nodes. In. Include. Ist es Include
oder Includes. Includes. Includes. Includes. Includes ist es. Target. Dann machen wir
nichts. Oh ne das bringt nichts. Das das bringt nichts. Das bringt nichts. Es kackt ab weil
es deine Selection löscht und dann nichts resiten will. Es funktioniert ja. Das ist
ja grad der Witz. Wenn man das auf Instance of Circle checkt dann geht das. Das heißt
es muss irgendwas anderes sein was der resiten will. Ah wahrscheinlich sind es noch mehr
Sachen. Wartet mal. Wartet mal. Wir loggen mal das Event. Nö. Hä. Was zum. Ok kein
Schimmer. Muss ich vielleicht sowas wie prevent oder sowas. Stop. Warte mal java javascript
stop propagation oder sowas machen. Event prevent default. Wie warum gibt es das nicht.
Ah man. Was ist das. Isst ihr was. Ich mache jetzt 5h time. Mein Circle kriegt jetzt kriegt
jetzt ein eigenes. Ein eigenes Attribut was ich checke und mein QR Code auch. Mir fällt
mir fällt. Ich habe keine Ahnung woran es liegt. Äh wovon mache ich denn hier. Insert
QR Code. QR Code hier. Image. Wo kann ich den Kram jetzt hinzufügen. Image. Adress.
Image. Adress. Content. Also ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Plan warum das abkackt. Aber
wir checken jetzt einfach. Target. Adress. Content. Und nur wenn das der Fall ist dann
machen wir was. Es kackt nicht mehr ab. Ich weiß nicht warum es abgekackt ist aber es
kackt nicht mehr ab. Der Preis Champ ja da waren die Crawler zu aufwendig zu pflegen
das habe ich keinen Bock mehr drauf gehabt. Ich weiß nicht ob wir da ein Kommando für
haben. So und wie kann ich das jetzt noch größer machen. Wie kann ich das noch größer
machen. Das ist doch Müll so. Wie kriege ich denn jetzt. Margin oder sowas. Margin ist
gut. Margin. Null. So schon viel besser. Schon viel besser. Und jetzt die Size. Scale.
Ach hier. Ne. Höhebreite geht auch. Also. Witz. 500. Höhe 500. Richtig schön fetter
Pepo Fett QR Code. Jawoll. Ein Pepo Fett QR Code. Da sind wir. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Was passiert denn. Wenn ich das hier jetzt runter skaliere auf
100 mal 100. Und dann vergrößere. Geht dann Qualität. Nicht Height. Nicht Weight. Alter
nicht Pepo Fett Gewicht. 70 wie. Das ist doch fragwürdig. Guck mal. Der ist schlau.
Guck mal. Der ist High IQ. Der scale das runter. Aber du verlierst beim Großscalen kaum Qualität.
Weil das 500 mal 500 unter der Haube ist. Wird SVG sein. Ne das ist kein SVG. Das ist
kein SVG. Das siehst du daran. Wenn ich 50 50 mache. Dann ist es pixelig. Dann kann
ich das nämlich einfach groß rendern. Das ist ein Bild. Groß rendern und dann kannst
du es eigentlich so fett machen wie du willst. Letztendlich wird es eh auf die Größe vom
Etikett am Ende runter skaliert. Was 36 x 39 mm sind. So das ist schon mal nice. QR Code
haben wir am Start. Jetzt die nächste Frage. Wie kann man ein Bild copypasten? Also wir
haben schon mal ein QR Code. Das ist schon mal gut. Braucht man immer wieder. Text wird
noch mal eine ganz extra eklige Geschichte. So wie kann man Bilder copypasten in JavaScript?
Paste Image from Clipboard. Hier Paste Image from Clipboard using JavaScript. Ja aber wie
heißt das Event? Wie heißt das Event? Das ist doch grad die Sache. Was? Document on
Paste oder Window at Event Listener on Paste? Ok. Also können wir noch sowas hier einfügen.
On Paste? Kennt er nicht. Na ja. Gucken wir mal ob es das denn gibt. Handle Paste. Nee.
Key Down. Ctrl V. Nee. Handle Paste ist ein extra Event. Paste Event. So schauen wir mal.
Log Event. So ich copypaste jetzt was. Clipboard Event. Nice. Funktioniert doch. So jetzt
müssen wir mal ein Bild copypasten. Heck weh. Kann man auf Bilder drücken ohne dass man
Angst haben muss Toss zu sein? FFZ. So Copy Image. So wie sieht denn das jetzt aus wenn
man so ein Bild einfügt? Clipboard Event. Paste. Clipboard Data. File List Items. Boah
wie bedient man das? Wie bedient man den Kram? File List? Stand da irgendwas? File List?
Song Define. Achso ich hab. Copy Image? Nee. Ja wie heißt denn der Kram denn jetzt? Clipboard
Data. Clipboard Data. Alter. Javascript ist immer so nice ist zu ein Error. Upload Schaltfläche
doch auch aber Copy Paste ist das beste was es gibt. Du hast doch die Bilder nicht erst
als Datei auf der Festplatte. Was wird programmiert? Ein grauen Kreis den man über den Bildschirm
bewegen kann. So Clipboard Data und was jetzt? Items. File List? Ja was denn jetzt? Items?
Data Transfer Item List. Null. File List? Alter. Javascript wie funktioniert denn der
Scheiß man? Ach nee einfach nur Files heißt es jetzt auf einmal. File List. Image PNG.
Boah. Wow das ist ja ein ätzender Krempel. Ok Files. Also Let File. Ja Docs lesen. Jetzt
pass mal auf. Massive. Massive. Neues Javascript Feature. Guckt mal. Wisst ihr was das macht?
Das ist absolut High IQ Javascript Feature. Kann man auch so schreiben? Kann man auch
so schreiben? Nee kann man nicht. Der guckt ob es das nullte Element gibt und wenn nicht
ist das hier halt null und ansonsten das Element. Das heißt man muss jetzt nicht explizit checken.
Vielleicht muss ich das jetzt aber so nochmal überprüfen wahrscheinlich dass es auch funktioniert.
If File. So und wie lese ich das jetzt? Moment da war mal noch hier irgendwie was gerade gehabt.
File Reader. File Reader. Reader. Ich hab keine Ahnung was ich hier mache. Reader.
Load. Read As Data Ull. Das klingt gut. Read As Data Ull. Und jetzt einfach sagen File
Let Data Await vielleicht noch. Nee. Ach nee ist nicht Async. Avoid. Nee. Await. Using
File Reader App in Async Functions. Der rappt das selbst in den Promise. Was? Du brauchst
on Load? Ok wir gucken mal in die Docs rein. On Load. Lese Vorgang erfolgreich beendet
wird. Ah. On Load End ist mit Fehler oder? On Load brauche ich. Also was? Reader. On
Load. Und dann hier Result. Wer hat sich denn diese API ausgedacht? Keg. Keg Triple U.
Result. Was zum? On Load. Event Target Result. Was? Nee Moment Event gibt es ja nicht bei
mir heißt es schon so Result. Ach du Scheiß. Wobei Moment das bezieht sich ja auf den Reader
also kann ich wahrscheinlich einfach Reader Result machen. Moment ich brauch nochmal das
Image. Wo ist mein Keg W Image? Das Keg W Image ist weg da hier. Das brauch ich nochmal.
Copy Image. Hey das Funst. Leute. Das ist Keg W. Keg W als Base 64 PNG. Es gibt eine
neue API. Ja welche denn? Nach was muss ich gucken? Sag mal nach was muss ich gucken?
Da mach ich das. Das ist Abfuck hier. Was ist das ja? So und jetzt Image wahrscheinlich.
Image vom Url. Ich will das gleiche wieder machen. Also quasi so Result. Image ja Höhe
brauchen wir nicht. So. Also wenn ich wenn du irgendwas neues weißt sag Bescheid. So
das kennen wir. So und jetzt Copy Paste. Bäm Leute Keg W ist am Start. Direkt im Canvas
drinnen. Guck mal und sogar relativ schön Anti-Alased wird der. Guck mal der wird besser
Anti-Alased als in meinem Tool. Mal checken was besser Anti-Alased ist. Nee meins ist
besser. Meins ist besser. Das ist einfach nur weich gezeichnet als fuck. Meins ist
besser. Wie hast du denn das Canvas gebaut? Mit Conver. Nice. Guck mal der kann sogar
Keg. Guck mal der kann Keg W flippen. Habt ihr das gesehen? Keg Flip. Das bräuchte ich
mal als GIF. Alter das ist. Dieses GIF fehlt noch. Keg Flip. Keg Flip als GIF. Was im Prinzip
einfach nur das macht immer in der Schleife. Keg Flip. Das brauchen wir. Keg Flip. Gibt
das schon als Emote? FFZ? Nee. Das muss man machen als GIF. Keg Flip. Wie macht man
gescheit GIFs für sowas? Keg Flip GIF. Das muss ich mir aufschreiben. Das wird das
neue. Ich sag euch das wird das neue Meta Emote. Keg Flip. Wo ist der Chain Law? Ja
wo ist der Chain Law wenn man ihn braucht? Keg Flip. Nee PDF einfügen kann ich glaube
ich nicht. Da müsste man das PDF wahrscheinlich als Image rendern oder so. Nice. Guck mal
es funktioniert. Wir brauchen auch mehr QR Codes Leute. Mehr QR Codes. Habt ihr mal
gescannt? Funktionieren die QR Codes? Stimmt irgendjemand hat gesagt er hat gescannt.
Keg. Nice. Guck mal ist das nicht ein schönes Label? Das ist doch Massive geiles Label.
Huge Label. Guck mal und das ganze bisher unter 122 Zeilen Code. Codra. Der Label Champ.
Man könnte das natürlich auch eine ganze gerade das hier auch eine ganze Ecke Modularer
machen. So. Einfach alles mit Keg W Labeln. So meinen Text brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
noch. Aber Text rauche ich mich heute Abend nicht ran aber ich mach schonmal ich mach
schonmal den Button für dahin. Texts. Texts. Text. Was ist ein schönes das da oder? Format
Text. Warum sind manche Sachen eigentlich hier mal rot und manche nicht? Und vielleicht.
Ich glaube das ist gut. Text. Ich glaube das ist besseres Bild dafür. Die roten müssen
gekauft werden. Ups. Ja doch brauche ich mehr Subs dafür da ich mir das leisten kann.
Flex Gap 2. Sehr schön. Ne. Gap X2. Nicht Y2. X2. Hä? Womit ist das jetzt noch breiter?
Willst du mich veräppeln? Guck mal das ist doch eigentlich nice. Das ist doch eigentlich
cool oder? Also die Eigens erkennt man so wir brauchen noch wir haben QR Code wir brauchen
noch einen fürs Bild. Format Textbox. Hm. Was findet ihr besser Format Textbox oder
das? Wir können das mal ausprobieren. Leute das da oder das da? Ah wobei ich glaube das
da. Wobei ich weiß nicht. Chat. Das da für Insert Text oder das da für Insert Text?
Überlegt euch. I Kriege. T. Der Chat ist sich ausnahmsweise mal einig das heißt schon
viel. Okay also so. So dann brauchen wir noch was für Image. Weil wir wollen ja im Zweifelsfall
auch für die Noobs die nicht gut Copy Pasten können eine Möglichkeit bieten ein Bild rauf
zu laden. Das machen wir hier dazwischen. Was heißt die Noobs? Ich bin ja eh der einzige
der den Krempel verwendet am Ende. So Bild hinzufügen also Text einfügen Bild hinzufügen.
Leute und jetzt wisst ihr was wir noch brauchen? Wir brauchen sowas hier. Jedes x beliebige
Material Design Icon einfügen. Das brauchen wir. GitHub MDE wie heißt das? Material Design
Font. Weep Icon. JavaScript install MDE JS. Jawoll. Fellby hat ne Frage. Wird das auf Shithub
gepublished? Ja warum nicht? Was wir geschafft haben ByteStrike. Guck mal wir können jetzt
QR Codes einfügen. Und und wir können Bilder einfügen. Bilder Copy Pasten. Guck mal. Und
wir können sogar Resizen die Bilder. Weeee. Kekspin. Das da macht noch nix. Das waren
immer noch QR Codes. So Material Design Icons wie funktioniert das jetzt? Ähm ich will
alle Material Design Icons rendern. Import MDE ok. Wait a minute ich will. Ich will nicht
nur das eine importieren. Ach du wa wie war da jetzt die Syntax dafür? Import Sternchen?
Nee. Import Sternchen? Z Variabler am Ende auch editierbar was meinst du? Ach du meinst
ob was vor oder hinter dem Element ist? Z Inex. Ja das können wir machen das ist ne
gute Idee. Ach S. Also S Icons oder sowas dann. Ok das funktioniert doch. Loggen wir
mal. Icons. Module. Oh. Oh mein Browser hängt. Ach da sieht man jetzt was alles drin
ist ok. Aha aha aha ok. Kann man da ne Schleife drüber machen? Icon in Icons oder so? Nee.
Da sind viele Icons drin. Ja ich will ja auch viele Icons drin haben. Wie iteratet man das
jetzt? Wie iteratet man das jetzt? Die Namen da drin? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ok. Iterate
Module Exports. Ok. Object Keys. Object Keys. Das schöne an Javascript ist es ist nicht
immer logisch aber meistens geht es. Ganz im Vergleich zu C++ da ist es nicht nur unlogisch
manche Sachen gehen auch einfach nicht so wie man sie sich vorstellt. Aha so hier hat
man 6.000 Moment wie viele Icons? 6.696 Icons. Das ist ganz hart an 69 dran aber die Kombination
gibt es hier nicht außer hier so in der Mitte. Object Keys Icons. Ok wie render ich denn
jetzt alle Icons? Das muss ich mal auspielen. Ok probieren wir mal was aus. Diff war so zum
Test hier oben drüber irgendwo. Also each. Each. Nee. Each. Icon. Nee Icons S Icon oder
so? Nee so so S Icon. Ah nee es ist ne. Hab ich jetzt each importiert? Ich hab each importiert
lul alter. Gewonnen. Und jetzt muss ich es irgendwie closen. Each. Ok. Und jetzt SVG.
Und was was was ist denn da überhaupt drinne? Moment Icons? Sekunde. Was ist denn jetzt
eigentlich Icons Icon drinne? Das SVG oder was? Ja das SVG ok ok. Also will ich jetzt
was machen? SVG? SVG? Ich hab keine Ahnung was ich hier treibe ehrlich gesagt Leute.
Kein Plast, Schimmer. Wie sieht überhaupt ein SVG aus? Data oder so? Nee. Nee. Pass?
Du hast direkt als Child rein den Text meinst du? Nee oder? Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Nee das funktioniert nicht. Nee nee das funktioniert nicht. Ja stimmt wir sehen die Icons hier unten
aus. Das ist ne gute Idee. Pass hier. D? D? D für Data? Wollte man da Bites sparen
oder was? Oder kann man einfach nur Pass machen? Nee. D. D. Yep D. So? Ist das denn
der Way das zu machen? Hey guck mal. Wir haben alle Material Design Icons jetzt da drinne.
Das funktioniert? Ok. Ich hab ne Idee. Massive Idee. Wir machen das jetzt so. Also wir brauchen
was für Icons. Ein schönes Icon für Icons. Gibt es ein eigenes MDE Icon für MDE Icons?
Nimm mal so ein Smiley. Happy, happy, happy face. Ok Button. Nach Text ist das wahrscheinlich
das häufigste. Text. Oh jetzt haben wir hier ein Icon. Nice. Und den Mist den wir hier
oben machen. Da machen wir jetzt so nen Ausfahr. So was was ausfährt hier oben drüber. Also
quasi noch mal so was hier oben drüber. Zum Durchsuchen mit Weltanimation oder sowas.
Das müssen wir mal schauen. Also quasi noch mal so was. Mit Suche. Oh jetzt wirds jetzt
wirds advanced Leute. Um den Import besser zu machen und dann nicht mit SVG Text rum
zu wursten. Ja wie stellst du? Wie denn? Ich hab keine Ahnung wie ich den Import anders
machen soll da oben. Das verstehe ich nicht wie das anders gehen soll. Keine Ahnung.
Ja aber Serious Max ist in 6000 Icons. Ich kann auch nicht 6000 da oben hinschreiben.
Nein nein ich will alle Render. Das ist ja Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Wenn ich den krempel.
Ich will alle. Ja ich will alle. Ich will so nen Selector machen. Also wir machen jetzt
noch mal ein zweites. Wir machen jetzt noch mal ein zweites. Diff. Exakt genauso wie
das hier. Nur das es höher wird. 30 oder so. Oder sagen wir mal ein Drittel. Irgendwo
sollte hier Keck drinne stehen. Machts aber nicht. Ah Moment wir müssen ja auch bottom
14 anfangen. Jetzt müsste da aber Keck drinne stehen. Warum steht da kein Keck drinne? Ah
weil ich es falsch hab. Ne. Warum steht da nix drinne? Chat? Irgendjemand Plan? Ah weil
er das Diff zugemacht hat. Alter der Kacknoob. Äh. Jetzt. Gibt es dafür keinen fertigen
Icon Picker? Bestimmt aber bestimmt keinen der hier schön reinpasst. Jetzt bestimmt
fertige Icon Picker. Ok machen wir jetzt hier. Let Show Icon Browser. Browser gleich. Mach
mal True. So. Und da rendern wir jetzt alle Icons rein. Also das geht da nur auf wenn
man da draufklickt. Soweit die Theorie. So. Each. Ne das ist schonmal doof. Leute jetzt
müsst ihr mir mal helfen. Wir machen jetzt ein Crit. Ich bin aber unfähig CSS Crit zu
verwenden. Crit. Crit. Column 4 oder so. Ich sag doch ich bin unfähig CSS Crit zu verwenden.
So funktioniert das schonmal nicht. Erstmal die Viewbox setzen. Ja. Das ist schonmal gut.
Also was braucht man denn hier jetzt noch? Wie geht denn das Viewbox setzen? Viewbox.
Was haben wir denn hier unten für eine Viewbox? Viewbox. Ok. Ich übernehme das jetzt einfach
mal. Jetzt ist gar nichts mehr da. Jetzt ist jetzt ist alles weg. Wahrscheinlich weil ich
jetzt noch die Breite setzen muss oder? W12. Aha. Aha. Da sind wir Leute. Da sind wir.
So. Breite. Full. Ne. Ah. Ok. Schon. Schon besser. Schon besser. Was weiß ich. Zehner.
Zehn. Das sieht gar nicht mal so. Das sieht gar nicht so ultra beschissen aus muss ich
sagen. Ah wie scrollt man dann jetzt hier drinnen? Aber erstmal hier Text. Cray. 100.
Wie krieg ich denn da jetzt ne Farbe? Ne. Wie kriegt man da jetzt ne Farbe hin? Color?
Ah. Ah. Phil. Aber ich will doch da kein Text angeben. Also Phil. White wird wahrscheinlich
funktionieren. Current Color. Current Color. Und dann kann ich wahrscheinlich sagen Text
Cray 100. Testen wir mal ob das funktioniert. Ah. Oh 5000. Gag. Ja nice. Ok. Äh wie kann
ich das dazu überreden? Zu scrollen jetzt? Ich finde das durchaus ok. Wenn der keine
Scrollbar hat. Die Dinger sind ein bisschen groß oder? Machen wir mal 8. Wobei ich will
es auch auf mobile benutzen. Machen wir mal 12. Dass man den Kram auch erkennt. Scroll.
Was macht man hier? Ne Overflow. Overflow oder? Overflow. Auto. Ne. Overflow Scroll.
Ach Moment das ist ja auch falsch. Das ist ja auch falsch. Ich will das ja auch nicht
da. So ich will das da haben. Scroll. Y. Und das ist aber bitte Auto oder so. Damit
es nur ist, wenn da auch. Das sieht kacke aus. Gibt es nicht die Möglichkeit, dass ich.
Jetzt das ist Hellwind ja. Der Chat ist im Weg. Stimmt. Chat. Sagt doch was. Ihr seht
doch gar nichts. Lull. Chat. Ihr müsst jetzt mal da oben hin. Da seid ihr weniger im Weg.
Ihr seht die ganze Zeit schon von der Anwendung nichts. Weil der Chat drüber ist.
Da oben passiert eh nichts gerade. Jetzt mal. Kann ich nicht. Kann ich nicht den Scroll
weg machen. Aber trotzdem Mausgrad Scrolling erlauben. Geht das nicht. Kann ich nicht.
Disable. Scroll. Bar. Butt. Keep. Scroll Functionality. Was? Visible? Guck mal hier
Hide Scroll. Wir hatten das sogar schon mal offen. Also was muss man machen? Scroll Bar
with none. Das geht nur im Firefox angeblich. Ok. Das muss jetzt als Style machen. Das
gibt es glaube ich in Tailwind nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das angebe. Wie gebe
ich sowas als Inline CSS überhaupt an? Da bin ich zu noobig für. Dann machen wir hier
Class. Disable. Scroll. Bar. Style. Disable. Scroll. Scroll Bar. So. Wie ging das? Ok
ich Copy Paste mir das jetzt einfach. So. So. Ah. Aber das Scrawlen geht. Das Scrawlen
geht. Nice. Es funzt Leute. Es funzt. Es lässt sich Scrawlen. Nice. Ok. Damit kann
ich leben. Und jetzt brauchen wir noch eine Search Bar obendrüber. Irgendwas das man
den Krempel auch durchsuchen kann. Also. Search Bar. Input. By the way. Wo ist es denn besser
drauf zu Scrawlen? Im Ganzen? Oder nur hier drin? Wobei es macht wahrscheinlich keinen
Unterschied. Also Input. Ja sowas. Sielle sowas werde ich wahrscheinlich auch machen.
Input. Placeholder. Search. Oh. Das Flex muss weg. Weird Flex. Was bist du von Beruf? Also
gelernt habe ich mal Fachinformatik. Achso das geht jetzt hier nicht. Warum will ich
es überhaupt Flex anzeigen? Gibt keinen Sinn. Gelernt habe ich mal Fachinformatiker System
Integration. Vor längerer Zeit. X2. Ja so ist es besser. Max versucht seine Arbeit zu
erklären. Ja genau. Da haben wir schon zig Clips für. So das sieht beschissen aus so
wie es ist. Aber mal richtig hängen geblieben sieht das aus. Also volle Breite. Padding.
X2. Nee. Was? Padding. X2. Oder PX2. So ist es schon mal besser. Was ist das für eine
Schriftart? Wait. Text. LG. MLG Legit. Und Text. Grey. 900. So. Schon mal viel besser.
Es ist jetzt zwar vielleicht keine Augenweite an Scrollbar. Wir machen noch ein bisschen
Margin unten drunter. Aber das geht schon mal durch als Scrollbar. Leute das Scrawlen
funktioniert wieder nicht mehr. Das Scrawlen ist wieder kaputt. Warum ist das Scrawlen
wieder kaputt? Warum? Eben ging es doch noch. Scroll. Auto. Nee was war das? Scroll X. Hab
ich schon wieder vergessen. Scroll. Overflow. Overflow war es. Overflow Y Scroll. Ah nee
Overflow Auto haben wir doch. Kann mir irgendjemand schlüssig erklären warum durch das Input
Feld die Scroll Funktionalität jetzt weg ist? Die scrollt jetzt auch nicht mehr. Weird Flex?
Warum nicht? Dass der oben einen Flex hatte wird es ja wohl kaum sein. Warum genau muss
ich? Hä? Ich hab absolut nicht den plassesten Hauch. Obvius ja. Nicht den plassesten Schimmer
warum das so ist. Ich hab keine Ah ja dann ist es mal wegen Weird Flex. Auch okay lass
ich mir gefallen. Input. Ja dann brauch ich aber Flex Row oder sowas brauche ich dann
dass es untereinander ist. Alter macht keinen Einfluss. Keine Ahnung warum? Wo ist das Problem?
Wir machen jetzt die Suche den Rest lass ich so das ist mir sonst zu anstrengend CSS Kram.
Rounded. Gib dem Ding mal ne Fixed. Naja 33% vom Bildschirm ich will das ja keine das
soll ja gar keine Fixed Height haben. Ich mein ich kann sagen dass der das komplette
ausnutzen soll. Bringt aber zum scrollen auch nichts. Keine Ahnung. Wir machen jetzt erstmal
die Suche. Es hängt mir noch ein bisschen viel in der Mitte sagen wir mal. Ja das ist
besser so oder? Jetzt hängt es nicht so. Also wir filtern das jetzt. Wir filtern jetzt
die Icons. Also Input Bind Value gleich Tja Icon Filter oder sowas. Das gibt es ja nicht.
Icon Filter gleich. So CACW. Input Spellcheck off ja da hast du recht. Spellcheck false.
So ein Müll sonst wird es underlined weil man hier so Testkrempel eingibt ja ja da hast
du recht das ist gut. So jetzt brauchen wir quasi sowas wie Filtered Icons, Object, Keys,
alle Icons ist Default. So und jetzt müssen wir gucken wenn sich Icon Filter ändert.
Oh jetzt wirds. Ne wir wollen checken ob Icon Filter überhaupt gesetzt ist. Wenn Icon Filter
gesetzt ist dann sagen wir Filtered Icons gleich das da oder Filtered Icons gleich Filtered
Icons gleich Filtered Icons. So und jetzt toLowerCase enthält das Icon unseren Filtered Texts.
Java Script CACW. Dann passt das ok wir suchen jetzt mal YouTube. Funktioniert nicht. Ah
weil ich Filtered Icons gar nicht verwende. Sondern ich verwende noch verwende das noch
mal. Nochmal das ganze. YouTube. Leute das funzt. Wobei Moment das ist kaputt. Das funktioniert
nicht. Das ist dumm was ich da mache. Immer. Immer so. So muss ich machen. So besser. YouTube.
Oh das laggt Alter das ist laggy. YouTube. Guck mal da. Ich muss sagen das sieht und fühlt
sich doch gar nicht so schlecht an oder? Ah Moment Default wert. Ja else offen Default
wert. Else. Das da. Dann kann ich das wahrscheinlich auch hier weglassen oder setzt das automatisch
Initial. Ja. Die bounds rein. Naja doch das laggt auch noch. Guck mal wenn ich das ganze
lösche dann laggt es jetzt erstmal weil es alle Icons neu laden muss. Und das ist ja
dumm änderung und die kannst du auch gar nicht. Ich mein wir könnten jetzt das machen
was die coolen Javascript Leute machen. Einfach nur das laden was man sieht. Aber das ist
ja weird champ oder? Also laden was man sieht ist eigentlich nicht unser Style. Das darf
gefälligt. Das darf schon gefälligt alles geladen werden. Wir haben den ram. Ich mein
die einfachste Variante ist ich mein wir wissen eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs. Sechs Spalten
kriegen wir hin. Also theoretisch könnte ich es relativ easy schnell machen. Aber ne ich
will ja dann auch scrollen später und sowas. Warum auch immer das scrollen grad nicht funktioniert
das ist wieder ein anderes thema. Ne ne. Weil wenn ich scrollen kann dann muss ich dann
auch gucken ob es in view gescrollt wurde. Und wenn es in view gescrollt wurde muss ich
es einblenden und so. Ne ne ne ne. Sowas machen wir nicht. Wir laden alles. Wir laden
alles und suchen dann. Icon. Bam. Guck fertig. So machen wir das. Hat irgendjemand einen
Plan warum dieser kack scroll jetzt nicht funktioniert. Das ist schon ein bisschen eklig. Muss ich
vielleicht hier scrollen drinnen. Scroll. Bar. Ne overflow ist das nicht. Over overflow.
Ach das geht oder was. Hä warum kann ich auf dem gesamten scrollen. Dann scrollt ja
auch die die die die Suchleiste mit das will ich ja gar nicht. Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen
darf ich es hier auf das Crit nicht machen. Aber wenn ich das Input weg mache. Moment.
Mit dem Flex geht das. Was. Was hat das Flex hier mit zu tun. Das muss mir mal einer erklären.
Wenn ich da ein Flex hab. Dann funzt das mit dem scroll ansonsten nicht. Jetzt ist natürlich
die Positionierung hier von beschissen. Und ich dachte dann kann ich flex row machen aber
das funktioniert nicht. Warum funktioniert Flex Row nicht. Es ist Flex nicht Row. Column.
Flex Column will ich machen. Guckt mal wir haben es gefixt. Wir haben es gefixt. Wir
haben es gefixt. Ohne es wirklich zu verstehen und zu wissen aber. Ok nice. Das ist doch
richtig. Ich mein für eine publische Label. Ach so wir müssen jetzt noch gucken wie man
das edit. Also Leute wir machen kein track und drop. Das ist mir zu. Ach so. Disable
scroll. Scrollbar. Scroll geht. Scroll geht. Wir machen kein track und drop. Das ist mir
zu aufwendig. Was wir machen ist Doppelklick oder Klick oder irgendwie sowas. Also pointer.
Ne wie ist das? Curzer. Curzer pointer oder so. Ja pointer. Dann kriegen wir so eine Hand
und wenn man da draufklickt dann edit das. Das heißt wir brauchen jetzt ein onklick insert
icon. Function insert icon. So und wir kriegen übergeben den ehm ja Name. Den Name. Den
Name kriegen wir übergeben. Das ist besser. Also insert icon und der Funktion übergeben
wir jetzt wie das icon denn heißt. Was habe ich falsch gemacht? Keine Klammer und rum
rum. So und wenn man das jetzt richtig macht dann müsste ich bei einem Klick eigentlich
ein icon bekommen auf meinem Canvas was ich track und dropen kann. Also da muss ich jetzt
aber mal gucken. Conver SVG. Insert. Haben wir noch gar nicht geguckt. How to draw SVG
images on Canvas. Das können wir dann nämlich auch für unseren QR Code verwenden. Da machen
wir es einfach als SVG. Das ist viel besser. Wenn das das kann. Ne der konvertiert das
zu einem Image. In most cases you can use SVG image. Ok. Einfach so. Ne Moment ich habe
gar keine Data URL dafür. Sorry für die Frage aber welche extension ermöglichest
die Seite im localhost aufzurufen? Du musst einfach die Webseite lokal bei dir laufen lassen
oder was meinst du jetzt? Wenn die Webseite bei dir lokal läuft dann kannst du die auch
mit localhost aufmachen. Das ist kein TypeScript. Das ist ganz normales Java Script. Guck hier
keinerlei Type. Warum ist hier eine Type Definition? Ich habe explizit gesagt kein TypeScript
Anzeige ist raus. Direkt. Ich habe ein Svelte Kid Projekt gemacht und habe das dann einfach
gestartet lokal und dann geht das. Unter der Haube startet das in lokalen Web Server und
liefert dir die Seite aus. Wie bekomme ich denn da jetzt eine Data URL? Was hast du gegen
TypeScript nix? Gar nichts. Wie bekomme ich denn jetzt daraus eine Data URL? Das ist nicht
ne Live Share ist was ganz was anderes. Oder habe ich die Frage nicht verstanden? Alter
ich habe den Chat sonst wo gehabt ey. Ne das Live Share ist was anderes. Live Share ist
wenn du mit Leuten zusammen programmieren willst zum Beispiel. Da kann man sich das
über Microsoft sharen. Live Server gibt es auch ja. Live Server ist aber in dem Fall
nicht notwendig. Live Server gibt es auch noch ja. Zur Insert Icon Name. Also das heißt
wenn ich da jetzt drauf klicke. Wenn ich da drauf klicke dann sollte jetzt der Name kommen
soll. Wie kriege ich denn jetzt von dem Name? Es hängt Leute. Es hängt. Ich hab mein Browser
kaputt gemacht. Mal kurz Seite schließen wieder neu aufmachen wohl. So hier. Ich krieg
dann ne Fahrt. Der bringt mir doch jetzt gar nix. Ich brauch ne Data URL. Ne ne. Mal ganz
davon abgesehen. Wenn ich das Image from url mache. Dann bleibt es ja kein SVG mehr
sondern wird ein ganz normales Bild. From url. Ja das funktioniert nicht. Ich hab irgendwelche
SVG Pass Geschichten. Da kann ich. Ok. SVG Pass to Data URL. Geht sowas? Moment. Echt
das funktioniert? Pass? Was? Stick Data Image SVG plus XML in front of it. So einfach ist
es. Ist das? Die zweite Option ist mit Pass. Ja aber ich will das mal kurz mit Image aus
probieren. Ob das so geht? Konver Image. Das probieren wir jetzt aus. Insert Icon. Also
was? Erstmal Icon. So das da. So und was soll ich in front sticken? Einfach Data Image
SVG. Das wird doch im Leben nicht funktionieren. SVG zu Data URL. Na dass es das als NPM gibt
wundert mich nicht. Es gibt ja irgendwie alles als NPM. Published four years ago. Was macht
der denn da? Java Skript Alter. Java Skript man. Huge Library. Wir klauen es jetzt einfach.
Jetzt wird es gerippt. Abgerippt. So. So wir loggen das mal und gucken ob das funktioniert.
Icon. Yoinkt. Genau. Icon. Nein. Das funktioniert nicht.
Broken Library. Das funst nicht Leute. Document is empty.
Ja. Muss das ein Komma oder ein Doppel. Muss das ein Komma oder ein Semikolon sein? Angeblich
ein Semikolon. Ja was denn jetzt? Komma oder Semikolon? Broken Library Alter. Invalid
Url. Ok. Nein. Keine Ahnung. Kegwaid. Nein. Das ist auch falsch. Nein nein nein. Gib
noch das hier. Wir suchen uns jetzt einfach. Wir suchen uns jetzt einfach bis wir in den
NPM Package. Ne wir können das auch mit Converpass machen. Alter weekly downloads. Was geht dann
mit dem ab man? Ok da macht schon ein bisschen mehr. Da macht da macht schon ein bisschen
mehr. Ich copy paste mir das jetzt trotzdem weil ich will kein NPM installieren. So. Also
wie verwendet man das jetzt? SVG to Mini Data Uri SVG. Ja Moment das ist so ein Path. Moment
das ist ja nur ein Path. Da muss ja tatsächlich noch mehr drum herum. Was? Stimmt man nennt
man die Schreibweise oder was? Was? Require? Monkeys? Moment wir machen das wohlgängig.
Das alte das alte war ok. Da muss noch SVG drum herum oder? SVG Path to Data Uri. Side
Point. Ok das ist klar. Side Point. Pass auf jetzt lande ich auf irgendeiner. Das ist
so ne Stack Overflow Rep Seite. Was was macht der Typ? XML Serializer? WTF? Ok es gibt keine
ordentliche Anfall auf Stack Overflow. Das ist auch schon einzigartig. Ich hab keinen
Schimmer. Installier einfach die Library. Weißt du wirklich das funktioniert? Ne welche
Library war es dann noch mal hier? Das da. Ok wir installieren die Library und dann schauen
wir mal ob es geht. NPM install. Ist das jetzt überhaupt so? Kann man das? Ist das überhaupt
im richtigen Format? Da sind auch nicht mal irgendwelche Examples drinne wie ich den Crampel
Gescheit verwende. Import. Usage. Require. Das ist das überhaupt nicht im richtigen Format?
Das ist irgendeine Node.js Geschichte. Oder so. Ne ne ne. Internet Explorer 9. Ok. Ok.
Also probieren wir das mal aus. Was? NPM install. Wobei ich weiß warum das nicht geht. Das ist
weil wir einen Pass kopieren. Guck mal da muss SVG und so noch davor. Hier. Wir haben
ja nur das. Das musste alles noch davor. Also im Prinzip wird das hier wahrscheinlich
schon funktionieren. Kann man JavaScript so? Übrigens habt ihr schon das beste neue C Sharp
Feature gesehen. C Sharp 10 bekommt jetzt String Literal. Du kannst jetzt in C Sharp
Python Kram bald machen. Passt mal auf. Aber nicht nur das. Die ist viel viel viel Pfeil
fertiger. Guck mal du kannst jetzt bald in C Sharp das da machen. Aber es ist viel cooler.
Du kannst nicht nur so machen. Du kannst beliebig viele angeben. Wenn du Sachen hier drinne escapen
musst. Und du kannst weiter Template Strings verwenden. Template Strings ist übrigens ein
gutes Stichwort. Das können wir jetzt auch verwenden. Du kannst dann hier beispielsweise
Dollar Dollar davor machen. Und dann musst du Curly Praise Curly Praise aufmachen drin
für Templates und sowas. Ich bin gerade verwirrt. Wo sind wir denn hier? Ich kann das auch irgendwie
gebacken kriegen. Ansonsten mache ich das auf die andere Variante. Was ist das jetzt
nochmal so in Javascript oder ist es so? So ist es. SVG. Und den müssen wir jetzt einfach
zumachen und dann SVG schließen. Pfeifert. String. Manipulation. Unescaped. Ok wir lassen
das. Was habe ich falsch gemacht? D nicht geschlossen? Ah D nicht geschlossen. Tatsächlich
D ist nicht geschlossen. Richtig. Stimmt. D ist wirklich nicht geschlossen gewesen.
So. Leute. Hat es jetzt? Ist das jetzt Weiter Vektor? Das ist Weiter Vektor Grafik oder?
Das ist Weiter Vektor Grafik. Sehe ich das richtig? Das wäre nämlich äußerst nice
wenn das Weiter Vektor Grafik ist. Viewbox 24 24. Was bedeutet das überhaupt? Dass es
in der Mitte ist. Was bedeutet Viewbox 24 24? Das ist ja offensichtlich Weiter Vektor
Grafik. So. Und das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Wo importieren wir denn hier nochmal
den QR Code? Das machen wir beim QR Code machen wir das auch. Ich kopiere mir den Krempel
mal kurz mit. Insert QR Code. Insert QR Code. So. To data URL. Achso wir kriegen den als
SVG. Kann man das nicht auch als SVG machen? To data URL. Ok Moment. QR Code hatten wir
doch hier irgendwie. GitHub. GitHub. QR Code. Node hieß der Krempel. SVG konnten die doch
angeblich auch. Wie geht das? Typ. To String. SVG. Ok also wir machen jetzt To String.
Im Text. Opts. Opts haben wir hier schon. Type. Jetzt können wir es auch kleiner machen.
Da sehen wir auch. Leute wir machen es mal kleiner. Dann sehen wir auch im Endeffekt
ob es ein SVG ist und man es ordentlich skalieren kann. Vektor Grafik FTW. SVG. Transparent
der Hintergrund ist ok. So und jetzt wollen wir das da machen. Ja Mr. Hanswurz schön
dass du deinen Weg her gefunden hast. Jetzt müssen wir aber vorher nochmal kurz checken.
Ich mach das mal weg. Jetzt müssen wir vorher nochmal kurz checken was da jetzt eigentlich
rauskommt. Wenn man auf QR Code hinzufügen drückt. Was kommt da jetzt raus wenn man auf
QR Code hinzufügen klickt. Ich würde das gerne bewegen. Ach guck mal da kommt schon
das komplette SVG raus. Da muss ich ja gar nichts machen. Da muss ich einfach nur SVG
to Data Ull machen. Und jetzt Image from Ull. SVG. Wie heißt das hier oben? Code. Code?
Kunst. Ohne Scale Leute. Ist das nicht Pog? Und es bleiben Vektor Grafik. Nice. Was ist
wenn der Link oder Text beim QR Code größer wird und damit auch der QR Code. Ach so ja
aktuell haben wir nur den Testtext drin. Aber das ändert sich ja nicht. Guck mal wir können
mal einen anderen machen. Wir haben ja hier. Das weiß ich wir machen hier längeren Text
sein. Massive Text für QR Code. So. Da pixelt nichts. Das ist Vektor Grafik. Guck mal. Da
pixelt nichts. So muss das sein. Das ist gut. Das gefällt mir. Lull. Das ist richtig
nice oder? Nice QR Code. Rechts noch eine Liste. Ich will es ja nicht verkomplizieren
weil das hier kann man mobile auch gut bedienen. Alles andere dann nicht mehr. Ok. Ach so ist
es eigentlich transparent? Das ist transparent. QR Code ist auch transparent. Pog alles transparent.
So. SVG to data ul. Mal chat meine Frage an euch. Was ist denn der Vorteil? Was willst
du von mir? Kommt das jetzt her. Was ist denn der Vorteil? Also warum warum so anstatt so?
Also was ist der Vorteil davon ist so zu schreiben? Keine oder? Warum die Scroll Funktion mit der
Search? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Jetzt gehts wieder. Hab da jetzt ne Flexbox draus gemacht
dann gehts. Const kannst du nicht mehr überschreiben. Ja aber wenn ich ne Funktion definiert
hab kann ich ja noch mal überschreiben oder ist das Javascript? Moment Moment. Blöde
Frage. Kann ich in Javascript sowas machen? Nee. Also warum? Wo ist der Vorteil davon?
Egal. Weißt was? Scheiß drauf. Weg damit. Und einfach wir machen das mal. Das können
wir irgendwie mal als Helper Funktion in extra Datei machen. Irgendwelche Scope Geschichten.
Okay. So. Aber ich bin echt begeistert. Das funktioniert wirklich wahnsinnig gut hätte
ich nicht gedacht. Okay. So. Was wollte ich jetzt? Ich wollte doch jetzt noch irgendwas
machen noch. Noch 15 Minuten lang. Suche haben wir gemacht. Ach dass das hier ein auspländen
geht oder? Woll ich das machen? Weiß ich nicht. Hab ich verdrängt ob ich das machen
wollte? Also der Knopf macht ja folgendes. Der insertet eigentlich kein QR Code. Der
sagt Show Icon Browser sagt der eigentlich dieser Knopf. Der insertet gar kein QR Code.
Der sagt das ist der was? Der erste? Zweite? Der zweite Knopf. Der zweite Knopf. Der sagt
gleich not. So. Und jetzt will ich diesen Icon Browser nur anzeigen. Was? Ja wäre
doch besser wenn es nicht die ganze Zeit da wäre. Jaja auf jeden Fall. Das ist bescheuert.
Das soll auch nicht die ganze Zeit da sein. So. Icon Filter. Show Filter. Show Icon Browser.
So dann machen wir jetzt ein If drum herum. Chat ich hab nochmal an euch eine Frage falls
ihr versteht worauf ich raus will und zwar ich hab jetzt ja die Möglichkeit zu sagen
wenn ich das rendern will. Moment wo sind wir denn überhaupt? Da. Hier. Da. So. Wollen
wir mal kurz hier. Icon Browser. So ich kann jetzt ja sagen if oder if. Ne. If. Mein
Gott's Welt please. If. Ich kann jetzt sagen if. Show Icon Browser. So. Jetzt ist er weg
und wenn ich da drauf klicke ist er sollte eigentlich wieder da sein. Ah ne es funktioniert
auch. Hallo please. Es laggt einfach nur. Es laggt einfach nur krass beim aufmachen Alter.
Ok was ist denn jetzt der Unterschied mal ganz im Ernst. Also das rendert er jetzt
conditional. So. Warum kann ich nicht einfach sagen class hidden. Show Icon Browser. Was
ist der Unterschied? Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem if und einer Klasse für hidden?
Die kann man lazyloaden wenn man sich Mühe gibt ja. Also warum sollte ich das machen
anstatt dem? Hat irgendjemand einen Plan? Ich nicht. Ich zeige euch mal das funktioniert
jetzt genauso. If wird nicht in das document tree. Mir egal ob der im document tree ist
oder nicht. Wird gar nicht erst gerendert. Es ist durchaus ok wenn es schon gerendert
wird. Ne so was wie ein view mit if show view if view show gibt es hier nicht glaube ich.
Ach deswegen lag das mit einem if auch mehr weil es hier schon im Vorfeld reingeladen
ist. Ja deswegen das geht auch schneller hier mit. Das merkt man richtig. So jetzt haben
wir das jetzt haben wir den Krempel jetzt können wir hier drinnen suchen. Wir können
suchen und wir können Dinge einfügen. Ich meine viel viel besser geht es hier eigentlich
gar nicht mehr. Jetzt können wir dazu machen. Das ist doch sehr nice. Da kann man sich nicht
beschweren. Und irgendwo habe ich einen console lock vergessen da. Ich muss ehrlich sagen
das da ist wirklich nicht schön ja. Aber es funktioniert ziemlich gut. Dafür dass es
nicht schön ist. Das finde ich cool. Das gefällt mir echt richtig richtig gut hier
gerade. Da kann man doch schicke Labels machen somit. Wirst du die Elemente an crit snappen?
Ja das habe ich mir überlegt. Da gibt es sogar ein Beispiel für Bacconver. Also crit
snappen nicht aber dass man die Elemente aneinander snappen kann. Und ich muss hier noch im Hintergrund
einplenden. Die Größe vom Label das man sieht wo man sich eigentlich bewegt wird noch
refactored. Also das hält sich aktuell noch in Grenzen. Das ist ja eigentlich verhältnismäßig
ordentlich. Achja irgendjemand meinte vorher nicht soll das so machen. Machen die coolen
Leute das so in JavaScript. Chat was ist besser so oder so? Das ist sehr cool ja. Nice. Was
ich damit machen will? Ich will Labels designen können für meinen Label Drucker. Was kann
man damit? Es fehlt bloß noch um Text zu inserten. Aber das machen wir heute nicht mehr wir haben
bloß noch 5 Minuten Zeit oder 10 Minuten Zeit. Gibt es irgendetwas was man auf die schnelle
machen könnte? Achja Leute ich weiß was wir machen. Das war noch auf die Schnelle. Animation.
Animation wenn das Ding aufgeht. Import. Import. Gibt es da nicht ein gescheites Makro für?
Import. Svelte. Transition oder was? Animation? Ne. Animate? Ne Transition ist es glaube ich
schon. Blur. Fade. Fly. Ne. Einfach nur Fly. Svelte. Fly in. Ich kann mir das nicht merken.
Ne CSS Transitions können wir so nicht nehmen weil CSS Transitions sind schwierig von versteckt
zu rein. Import. Svelte. Transitions ist doch richtig so. Oder Fade. Wir machen einfach
mal Fade. Ne ja Fade reicht. Fade. Fade. Und dann sagt man glaube ich einfach nur an
der Stelle Fade. Aber dann muss man es mit If machen. Svelte das checkt glaube ich.
In. Fade. Da muss man das mit dem If machen glaube ich dass er das checkt mit dem Fade.
Was natürlich doof ist weil das If ist langsam. Probieren wir das nochmal kurz aus. Also wie
war das jetzt so war für den If ne? Show Icon Browser. Ah. Das Problem ist dass es
erst Faded wenn die Icons geladen sind. Man müsste die Icons spielt und man müsste es
erst aufmachen und dann die Icons laden. Wie auch immer man das macht rendertechnisch.
Kein Plasenschimmer. Ich mein die coole Variante wäre zuerst aufmachen, ne Spinner anzeigen
und dann irgendwie die Icons laden wie auch keine Ahnung wie man das ordentlich macht
in JavaScript. So einfach nur Fade. Oder muss man jetzt in Fade out Fade machen. Ja. Das
sieht weicher aus. Ich mein das ist so ein bisschen zu langsam. Ja wir müssen Duration
noch machen. Nochmal setzen auf irgendwie was halbwegs erträgliches. Duration 2 Sekunden
ist ja deutlich deutlich zu lang für. Guck mal. Das 50 Millisekunden oder so ist vielleicht
sinnvoll. Während ich Fly von unten cooler. Bestimmt. Die Sache ist nur die. Solang das
leckt wie Sau beim Klick. Ah das ist ja kein Sinn. Wenn es nur Faden soll kannst du die
Opacity. Oh das ist ne gute Idee. Das ist ne gute Idee. Das kann ich tatsächlich die
letzten 2 Minuten nochmal testen. Opacity. Also machen wir das mal weg. Also haben wir
Class Opacity gleich. So Null. Ne. Achso. Show Icon Browser. 100% oder Null.
Nö. Nö. Was macht man das überhaupt so?
Setzt man das überhaupt so? Ach ne. Man setzt das. Achso. 1 ist komplett. Achso. Geht
aber auch so nicht. Ja dann weiß ich auch nicht. Keine Ahnung. Opacity 25. Aber prinzipiell
funktioniert es doch. Doch doch. Class ist richtig. Hä? Achso stimmt. Ja Moment Moment.
Ne Stylebinding gibt es nicht. Ich bin ja auch blöd. Das muss halt tatsächlich so sein.
Irgendwie 100. Null. Irgendwie so. Tatsächlich ja. Alter ich bin halt zu dumm für. Ach ne.
Das muss Opacity 100. So müsste das sein. Ne. Gibt es Stylebindings mittlerweile? Ja
Moment. Aber warte mal. Leute wenn das Ding. Wenn das Ding Opacity 100 oder Opacity Null
hat. Ja. So. Das man das man das. Da kann ich das eh immer noch anklicken. Ne das ist
dumm. Das will ich net. Da muss ich was anderes einfallen lassen. Wie kann man das. Wie kann
man das. So Async Loan. Wie macht man sowas? Keine Ahnung. Aber ich geh jetzt auch glaub
ich gleich pennen. Pointer Events. Ne. Das ist das ist ja abartig. Alter. Ne ne ne ne.
Wie krieg ich. Wie krieg ich das hier Async Loan? Gar nicht wahrscheinlich. Ja das ist
mir klar. Ich könnte gucken was im Kennen was angezeigt wird und nur die rendern. Aber
das ist mir zu aufwendig. Weil da muss ich ja gucken. Was in View ist und dann ein und
ausplanen und so. Das ist doof. Svelte Svelte Component Async. Async Component. Await Import
MonkaS. Ok. Das mach ich jetzt nicht. Das das mach ich jetzt definitiv nicht. Das sieht
sehr MonkaS mäßig aus.
So.
Ja die gucken, wenn was in view ist, auf die Idee bin ich auch schon gekommen.
Ja das, das müssen wir mal gucken, das, das müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir das, wie wir
das machen können.
Auf der anderen Seite, das ist halt einfach lag.
Ich mein, der insertet einfach 7000 Dom-Elemente und das wird wahrscheinlich nur einfach laggen.
Da wird man wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel dagegen machen können.
Kann man, gibt es die Möglichkeit, in die Schleife an Await einzubauen, dass der einfach
immer 20, 10 Millisekunden wartet oder so nach, nach dem er was gerendert hat.
So machen die meistens auch.
Ja da muss ich mal gucken, wie man das, wie man das macht.
Egal Leute, ich geh jetzt pennen, wir sehen uns morgen früh und ich schieb den Chat mal
wieder runter.
Bis dann, machts gut, CU.